the end game he can match Magnus there
and there is a big threat black is
threatening the white F2 Pawn uh the
Black Knight the black Dart squared
Bishop eyeing up that one and suddenly
it's not so easy for Magnus to
coordinate his pieces it feels like the
white pieces are kind of Here There and
Everywhere blacks pieces especially the
two Bishops pointing in the same
direction coordinating well Magnus Under
Pressure yeah there's some practical
problems to solve for Magnus he has won
the bond but that F2 Pawn under attack
he does a nice defensive move there just
moves The Rook up to D2 freeing some
space for his other Rook to come into
the game he has an extra Pawn but
practically still not easy yeah this is
what we call compensation it's often
vague you're like what is that
Grandmaster mean when they use a term I
think they're just trying not to talk
too deeply about the position but we
can't hear blacks Bishops they're aiming
across the board the knights for black
they're connected with one another
they're also threatening the F2 Pawn as
we're highlighting so this is dangerous
territory for Magnus Carlsen one mistake
could actually really cost him because
we think without Queens on the board oh
just an end game this is not an end game
it's a queenless middle game with
attacking chances Black's King safe from
the corner White's King could be in some
danger and watch out for the back rank
you may forget about it for now but at a
critical moment you might have to spend
a much-needed Tempo to give your king
some Loft and then the other side can
take advantage of it so I do like this
position for vladisal protea but you
need to prove it because if you're not
accurate here the extra Pawn will make
his presence fell yeah some big threats
on the board if I might tell me if I'm
looking to try and attack the opponent's
pieces gain time in the process this
Rook is asleep doing nothing why not
centralize it why not gain time against
the white Bishop uh here I don't think
Magnus really wants to give up the
bishop pair for example you could trade
off a set of minor pieces here hoping to
alleviate the pressure but in reality
he's just opened up the black Rook this
Black Knight replaces its counterpart
and uh again pressure on the white
position uh also in the current position
is Artemis thinking of capturing this
Knight doubling racking the white pawns
it is committal again Bishops here are
the most valuable commodity you don't
really want to trade them off unless you
get something immediate turn but for
example you could trade off this night
drop back with your own Knight
threatening a monster Fork a family Fork
if you can capture this Pawn on F3 all
sorts of tricks in the air uh plenty of
choice here for artemiev and he has a
Time Advantage so this is the current
position does he take this Knight does
he just bring his Rook into play what do
we think here who would you pick this is
tough this is absolutely tough here
especially because that Pioneer I am
going to take Magnus in this position of
course because I do have obviously
obviously the extra Pawn but man at that
time Advantage is I'm definitely going
to start filling it in two minutes from
now I'm not gonna have really any time
if I'm Magnus here that's gonna be
really tough to try to convert this
right and there's compensation of course
it's Artemis move work a to E8 is very
strong hits the bishop it makes me make
some type of decision here maybe I could
go Rook E1 in that case but I mean it's
very difficult and you have to be very
very precise in this uh in this next few
moves yeah and this is why vlades live
our time you have is such a dangerous
opponent he has this willingness to play
strategic battles as well as fight
flawlessly for initiative currently with
the initiative is a Vlad he is down upon
but as David you pointed out there is a
lot of play that black has he is going
into a bit of a thinking he can't afford
to fall too low on the clock because he
needs that time to build the initiative
and I like your idea of just playing
simple bring that Rook into the game
bring all the toys to the nursery yeah
but it's always simpler when you're not
facing Magnus Carl we're here we're
going to talk about the chest we see the
eval bar going back and forth we can
bring up stock for suggest so we don't
even have to guess what should happen
but for vladis over attemptive he knows
he is down material and that is
psychologically difficult and thank you
to our production team to bring up those
suggestions rookie eight looks good
Bishop takes F3 also looks good but the
point is one of those moves say rookie
eight you don't hurt White's Pawn
structure you're just bringing Rook to
Center you still remain down that pawn
that is scary psychologically when
you're playing the best player of all
time so our team if we know how stoked
he is we know he keeps everything under
control but right now there's a position
that can get out of control if he
doesn't actually make the most of his
conversation we're going to do a battle
of water right now white or black I'm
gonna start with you David uh black you
play with black but he needs to move
soon
James you're a big white or black I
gotta go with white yeah I'm gonna go
with Yasser serum I'm hungry I'm a pond
Grabber I'm taking that pawn and I'm
gonna run with it so I'm gonna take the
white pieces as well and that's on a
Magnus bias there no it's actually I do
like having the extra material all right
fair enough but I like the activities so
David I'm gonna agree with you I think
it's just so much easier to play with
the initiative there we've got James and
Robert doing fist bump we'll see
but of course he's just taking too much
time vlad's still in a big tank yeah
he's lost inside his own head here he's
getting carried away working out those
variations and okay finally he makes a
decision it's one of the best moves it's
one of the most natural moves but
burning four minutes or so burning all
his clock Advantage he needs to come up
with something in this position he's
forced Magnus to accept those double
pawns the white King has been uh kind of
compelled to step forward as well does
he have something immediate here what
was Vlad working out it should have been
this position that he was calculating he
should have been ready with a flurry of
quick moves but uh he's gone again into
a bit of a think and now it's Magnus up
on the clock Magnus gaining in
confidence with every sec that passes
and yeah now there's more at stake white
is still a pawn up but white also has
the bishop pair really useful long term
if all the Rooks disappear white is
going to win white is going to win the
same game so vladislava 10 we have
Stakes are higher than ever he needs to
move does it surprise you that he takes
this Monumental big decision of trading
the bishop makes this obvious move the
Knight Retreat to E5 Magnus replies in
the most human way to play King G2 and
then another big tank there yeah it's uh
surprising it's the type of thing I do
but that's why I'm not at this level
yeah he just needs to move get that Rook
from the corner into the game just a
natural move you don't need to look for
the best ones here just need to improve
your pieces the tactics will work in
your favor if your pieces are happy and
coordinated but uh yeah another long
think one minute pretty much half his
time on this move uh this position he
would have foreseen it what is he
thinking about it's uh it's a surprising
it's gonna do some tactics with like
Rook EA but I mean you are playing
Magnus you got to be careful here like
rookie eight and then obviously you're
hitting the bishop if the bishop goes to
the wrong Square you might have a knight
F3 in there then after King F3 maybe a
94 but the king might end up on G4
believe it or not there's some crazy
stuff here it takes and 94 threading the
bishop right but there's even Bishop F4
you play G5 right the rook's hanging
there's a lot of stuff going on here and
if I don't know King G4 is that even
possible getting out in the middle of
the street right now I don't know what's
going on but maybe he's trying to
calculate that yeah it's a deep line
right you can take that Rook the F2 Pawn
will fall everything is happening in a
position of this nature and rookie 8 the
starting move is in place but vladislav
he's down to one minute remaining and
Magnus he knows what's coming he is
going to see that tactic on the F3
square but I don't really know how to
avoid it maybe he could take the Knight
on F6 first that doesn't look like it
helps very much yeah I think he might
have to take this Knight unless you want
to go into that kind of maze of
complications in here the white Bishop
can Retreat maybe to this Square maybe
to this Square it does look a bit ugly
here for white I've got to admit this
white king now out in the open ready to
be checked by the black pieces but uh
Magnus okay he drops his Bishop back
instead this is playing with fire
everything is loose on this file on the
f file that black Rook is going to have
a huge say on the decision of this game
James you're looking for tricks here
you're looking for the same idea maybe
that you mentioned uh this Black Knight
can jump out the way I'm not sure which
Square it uses uh but again just so many
threats has Magnus got an answer to this
but notice how Magnus played his last
move quickly and now I'll tell me if
down to under 30 seconds Magnus is
hustling on the clock he still hasn't
made him move
I think James and I were right on this
one right it's just much easier when you
have the extra Pawn because when you're
down material I was like how do I get it
back make sure that I get activity but
Knight H5 what's the next thread of
course the bishop is under attack right
now you need to save that piece but what
is the follow-up it's not easy to see
that and he only has 17 seconds yeah I
call him the Iceman sometimes because
he's so calm so stoic but he froze in
that position the Iceman froze and he
really needed to move quicker you can't
navigate this type of position down a
pawn with only 17 seconds against
someone world-class like Magnus and okay
Magnus drops that Bishop back notice how
he's willing to trade pieces Magnus is
saying yes you can get rid of one of my
Bishops but uh okay I'll tell me if
steps back he's hoping for a repetition
of moves but can Magnus do better if
Magnus brings his Bishop back to F5
that's the second time we've seen that
position Magnus of course will want to
win he's got white he's got two minutes
extra and he's upper Pawn still and
we've got our first result of the day 11
aronian did win against Wesley so with
the black pieces what a start for lab
not just the result it felt like that
was a dominating game there Robert the
opening went wrong this is the chessable
Masters uh Wesley so has written a
course on one E4 so many hours of video
it looked like a D4 opening so maybe
I'll have to switch that up in the
future but Levon Ron came well prepared
and he is a man on a mission
absolutely so Wesley so trailing that
one and it looks like this one is going
to be tough
he's down to 15 seconds and he's
retreated the night do you see magnets
repeating moves here no okay I think
hell will freeze over before Magnus uh
goes for a repetition here and he's
retreated his Bishop
David with a bar what's up
right here Coe calculation over
everything get him off to the bar 94 for
the score King G4 is King out in the
middle of the street right now and what
do we do now age five and we live what
is this I don't understand H5 nope
Knight D2 wow and then F2 false as well
you just pick up the F2 Pawn oh my
goodness is this collapse on National
Television he's claiming that in an end
game use the King as a weapon but I
don't think that King should be
weaponized this early White's pieces are
discombobulated they're all over the
place that Bishop the light Square
Bishop it's blocked by its own King the
dark Square Bishop is under attack Hans
are hanging left and right and I feel
like for Magnus Carlsen things are
getting out of hand but last number 10
only has seven seconds he's gotta find
them four three oh he's gonna oh my God
he's gonna be inside
oh man he made that move for two seconds
left on his clock throws in a check
giving up a pawn trying to lure the
white king even further forward I've got
to say commentators curse I've said
Magnus would play on but he will be
regretting that decision look at that
white king how is it gonna survive if
you take that pawn now the black Rooks
are going to mobilize with time oh my
God we might see a Checkmate in this
game I've got to say guys
he's playing every move with one second
it's a three second incoming he's got
four seconds on the clock he made that
last move with a second he's panicking
our Tammy I don't like his last move I
was going to say material count white is
actually up white has a bishop a knight
for a rook you're up one point and uh if
one set of Rooks disappear suddenly
there are no mating attacks against the
white king suddenly white will be safe
so I'm expecting the white dark Square
Bishop to move or maybe the White Knight
Will centralize and attack disappearing
and I was just saying don't use the King
as a weapon this early but that white
king may actually slide forward and that
black king might be the one that's
checkmated you have to be very very
careful here because at some moment that
black king there are many white minor
pieces that can go after it this is not
looking easy at all I do not envy
artemio's task I think he's in huge
trouble but they're both in time travel
Magnus keeps thinking because it's a
tough position your H2 Pawn is hanging
you can't move your Bishop The Rook is
you're gonna end up trading Rooks which
is great for black but there's no way to
really fight the trade Robert are you
still picking Magnus for this one yeah I
am I just think the time trouble is
crazy and you have two pieces to just
Rook right so I think Rook D2 maybe
there will be simplification uh but I
just feel like there's no way mag is
going to lose this position like you
lose one of the two pawns either B2
fault or the H2 maybe you can lose both
actually it feels like they come after
the storm though even if you lose both
these white pawns as long as you can
kind of coordinate your minor pieces I
say if it's a big if but uh the white
king now will start centralizing look at
that black king it's nearly trapped
actually unfortunately you don't have a
rook or king or Rook or queen to mate
that black king but here we go whoa oh
big fella what is that oh he's about to
take on uh he's gonna take that yeah
he's training him
London is
not time to go it's over
he walked into a pin and I told you
float like a butterfly stand like a bee
and that one stings because Mangus and
losing it and had the white pieces the
boot that hurts that hurts and that is
it Magnus Carlton resigns after that
London Knight D6 Rook B6 that's a pin
you bend
you win the night that's a lost end game
that was still hoping for this but what
a roller coaster of a game was this was
David yeah what a roller coaster and
Magnus there you can see him looking
over the game trying to figure out where
he went wrong but it was actually the
momentum it was all in Black's favor big
blunder from Magnus earlier but uh after
all those twists and turns I'll tell me
I've took the point
wow wow this was such an up and down
game our Hots are beating so fast we
sure that yours are too our tummy
bounces back from a difficult position
to take that one away so many big
critical moments it's time for Aliso
vetta learning point
[Music]
for today's learning point we're
actually going to recap the final stages
the closing moments of that Goliath
battle between Magnus Carlson and
vladislav are Tami of so many twists and
turns as we mentioned that middle game
is well worth a study however it was in
the end game that this was decided and
this is a cautionary tale never switch
off don't lose alertness even deep into
the end game here Magnus with his Bishop
of Knight maybe thought he was reaching
safety maybe he thought the game was
steering towards the drawer he
centralized this Knight very logical
move but Artemis was full of Tricks he
threw his Pawn forward here in the
studio we were wondering what was the
point but after the pawn was captured
Rook to B4 attacks a bunch of things
attacking the pawn attacking the bishop
and the Knight through an x-ray here
Magnus has a few moves to keep the game
going but he needed to be alert he
needed to be accurate he should have for
example dropped his Knight back this way
just to defend the bishop instead he
defended from a different angle he
wasn't alert enough and uh suddenly he's
just stepped into a pin the black
retreated to the sixth rank the White
Knight is pinned to its king and that
was all she wrote that was the game and
Magnus had to resign
wow what a game that what a big win by
vladislav our time we have there's
action on in photos versus Hikaru Hikaru
with the white pieces he's not happy
he's not happy but that's because the
game is fizzling out to a draw perhaps
Hikaru was uh hoping that earlier he
could make something but uh yeah here it
looks like featherserve has defended
very accurately Bishop versus knight is
the only imbalanced symmetrical Pawn
same number of pieces but uh yeah very
easy draw from this point missed
opportunity maybe for Hikaru well that's
uh at least what his body language is
telling us yeah he's always amazing oh
come on
yeah come on Chad
oh this is ridiculous chat you know so
but I mean he he wants to win he you
love that type of spirit from someone or
a game especially car oil being an
official random world champion of course
he's uh just looking for that win and
especially after a feather say I mean
they have a very heavy beef there as
Robert mentioned I mean literally
beating Hikaru five the last five title
Tuesday games in a row oh there's
definitely some animosity there and he
needs to try to figure this out I mean
he wants to win the match now I've got
to say despite hikara's headshakes he
was actually the one who's a bit Lucky
in this game I think fedesev had a
winning move earlier uh if he had
spotted it but uh yeah in the end a draw
a fair result in this game
wow we've often seen so we've often
heard so many players say that Hikaru
his Expressions don't believe them on
camera yeah no it's a psychological
trick you know he's just like always
throwing his head left and right but
look at this position we have we've won
game left Fabiana car one I think we can
believe in him and his chances because
he has an extra pawn and now that Knight
for black it's stuck back there might
get trapped wow there's no way home for
that one yeah that black knight is
literally trapped it has no squares to
go to but if the white king retreats to
try and attack this Black Knight the
black king will Race Across and try
what's going on car was shaking uh sorry
Fabiano shaking his head there I think
he needed to backtrack he needed to go
for that black knight yeah that he's let
it out of the cage and now the Black
Knight don't trade yeah can you trip
because he gets opposition I think you
can trade these numbers is that just a
draw actually because you trade and you
you advance with your king and yeah
that's a drug that is it he just missed
it yeah no he had to go backwards so
attempting to lash out go forward in an
end game when you've passed on but we
see out position is secured from lemle
he is going to earn that half point and
Fabiano is going to be kicking himself
because he remains up a pawn but this
extra Pawn cannot promote the game will
end likely in a stalemate next few moves
and I think fobby honestly pretty
disappointed yeah you called it out
stalemate on the board wrong moment to
trade those nights there with that
immediately the game fizzled out wow
that was a big moment a big Miss by Fabi
because he could have trapped the Knight
David yeah a big Miss and uh if it's
possible I just want to show what
happened there because he let the Black
Knight out of its cage I think he could
have gone for the night trapped it won
it and Leanne would have had to resign a
few moments later it was this position
Fabi went in the wrong direction with
this King he stepped forward later
allowing this Black Knight out via the
C3 Square If instead he just raced
towards this night he would have won the
game there's no way out you're simply
going to go back and pick it up if the
black king steps across then it simply
isn't in time here the black king
attacks the Knight yes but you can jump
out of the way with the check and no
matter what black tries for example
going for the white porn white is just
in time to hold it defend it and win the
game so missed opportunity for Fabiano
caruana wow that was a big Miss by Fabi
but don't miss this opportunity to
subscribe to our twitch channels for our
non-subscribers we've got a break coming
up for those of you who have subscribed
do not go anywhere we have a very
special guest and a very special
interview coming up
[Music]
here's the chess streamer of the Year
Levy Rosman has arrived on chessable you
want to know how to counter the Sicilian
the French the Cairo Levy will show us
the way with one E4 he brings masterful
technique to bring in those wins with
white head over to chasable and start
upping your game today you've got to use
the command Gotham Chasse will to Master
One E4 and we've got the man himself
with us let's welcome on the show lovey
Rossman
lovey how are you can you hear us
yes yes I can sorry I didn't know if I
was supposed to introduce myself I was
waiting for your cue I appreciate them
saying I have masterful technique by the
way it says like gross exaggeration of
my abilities but thank you guys I I
really I'm humbled
we are so excited to have you here with
us I love you I don't think you need any
introduction to anyone in the world you
are the internet coach for the
chatsworld and you've just won a
streamer of the Year reward
congratulations on that how special was
it
uh yeah listen I'm never gonna win a
serious chess award I mean I won the K3
uh Scholastic championship of New Jersey
and I think I won the k6 also I've I
remember this because my dad said if I
win the tournament he was going to buy
me Fritz this was like many many many
moons ago maybe two decades ago
um it was you know it was it was a fun
feeling it was crazy to be in Los
Angeles I'm not really cut out for like
the lifestyle they have over there but
the weather is much better in New York
so uh it was a lot of fun and um I just
don't like seven hour flights so credit
to uh Robert and uh and and James
because I'm sure they had long flights
to get to Norway but I'm sure it looks
very nice over there it was very well
deserved and because of what you're fat
Lobby I have to buy the bullet and ask
you were you bothered by hikaru's
reaction
no no no no no
um you have to understand like that was
a 15 second clip in a six hour stream
and generally when you stream it's like
constantly getting badgered by the same
array of questions over and over so if
you ever tune into my stream and you
know there's a sample size of the same
question being asked 10 times I'm gonna
give you like 10 different responses two
of them will be serious and eight of
them will be ridiculous because I don't
think there's any other way to cope like
we were just talking about the streamer
Awards I don't know how these folks
stream 250 hours every single month it
would it would completely drive me nuts
so now you know he he's yeah he said
something a little Snappy a couple of
hours into the show but uh no I I think
there's far greater things to be
bothered by
Levy we're so excited about your award
and also this big drop on Chesterville
and I want to know for this big most
anticipated coach I think everyone's
been waiting for a course by you what
motivated you to make it on one E4 on
the kingspawn opening
um I think the lines are very practical
like uh I play a lot of E4 uh myself and
Blitz and I think I have the most fun in
Speed games I'm not playing a huge
amount of classical the problem is like
you know my goal is 24 2500 ELO and
Tanya you know you're a D4 player but
you know this it's scientific at that
point it's like you're not gonna get fun
positions almost ever like it's just
very kind of you know looking for that
minuscule advantage that stockfish
claims are following a game that was
played a couple months ago by some of
these great players for example that are
in the chessable Masters but for
99.9999 of chess players E4 brings the
most fun and challenging all of the
major black defenses is still completely
possible to do in a very fun and
exciting way without sacrificing much
Advantage
um so I decided to to make it on e4 and
it was like a heroic effort I mean we
put together a 1200 variation 18 hours
of video course and about two months so
but it's it's great I mean I've been
playing a lot like all these lines as
I've been drilling them and learning
them you know myself and learning their
subtleties and I'm winning about 75 of
the games and some of these variations
so uh of course in Blitz I haven't had a
chance to go to classical tournaments
um so yeah I mean I've had a blast I
love some of these lines uh and uh I
hope you know the audience will too
yeah Levy that's awesome to hear and I'm
sure people are you know diving right
into the material and I guess my
question for you is how do you choose
which opening is most fun because you
see some sacrificial openings but they
may be a little bit dubious how do you
actually choose which openings you're
going to play
that's a good point uh well I guess
there's like two things here first of
all there's what I'm gonna play with me
I I don't I don't actually care like I
had a king's Gambit phase you know it's
like pear for me uh although I mean it's
kind of falling out my dad um
unfortunately lost his hair quite early
so I won't be able to use that analogy
much longer but it's it's kind of like
having a hairstyle
um for me I can just like kind of play
whatever because it's sort of my my
style of Chess I don't really mind C4 D4
E4 B3 like whatever
um but for the course itself uh it we
did it in a very strategic way we did it
in a way where a lot of games have been
played recently where Grandmasters are
going uh to kind of get off the beaten
path uh but we've also done it in a way
where other chessable courses did not
cover those lines like there were a few
lines that I wanted to cover but I saw
you know maybe maybe gawaine Jones
already did a deep dive or Simon
Williams and I kind of went it just
doesn't make sense like I don't want to
reinvent the wheel because then you know
there's like there's chessable customers
that also will compare courses Side by
side and if you're just offering like
the same thing because at the end of the
day like I just said just a scientific
you can't just say oh I you know I
solved this variation when there's
already a good solution here
um yeah we did it in I mean in a very
similar way like that we chose our team
for protesting I mean we just sat down
we looked at all the details we uh we
ultimately made a decision and we tried
to keep the repertoire kind of
consistent while also offering some kind
of you know model and unique suggestions
that there's a line in the two nights
that
I recommend a move that has only been
played once ever and it was played three
weeks ago in a tournament in Europe
European Championship so just kind of
keeping up with like the modern Trends
uh while also recommending stuff that
you can't also find in five different
locations wow
that's amazing we're so excited about
this course and thank you so much for
taking all the time and joining us and
congratulations for everything that you
do and uh yeah we're looking forward to
more thank you so much for joining
Larry Osman streamer of the year is out
with his first course on chasable on the
king spawn opening so check that out
there's a short and sweet version for
free on that I've got a big reveal for
you by the way that is not the only big
drop on chassisville that's one more
course and it's by none other than our
very own James County
this right here is how I use chessable
and why I've been using it for a long
time I mean if you look up here I
actually have my streak it says
1231 days right you're gonna forget a
lot of the things that are in the book
Jessica came around when I got on
adjustable it's literally I was already
doing that so this is now a game changer
because I can do it faster it's online
it's in front of me all of my books are
here if they're gonna be folders now so
I can categorize my white black and I'll
tactics in game but I literally have
everything in one area as you see I'm
scrolling here this is what I like to so
they're like how many testable books you
got I'm like all of them how are you
stressable is actually I do a lot for
the opening training I do tactics on
here I do calculation I do in-game I do
everything but the database all my
training on here all the time adjustable
is the wave this is why I like to use
stressful it actually helped me I
remember even online I was only like
tapping out at 23.50 almost 2400 and and
Blitz and bullet my chest com is 26 with
a high of 27.74 on bullet and I blame
all of this if like success really it's
just working on chessable just being
honest with you
[Music]
hey you know what I'm saying the proof
is in the chest well baby okay that's
what they say right now Jessica is the
wave I definitely love uh adjustable
it's a great tool to use and my course
are coming out it's the meanest Joe
Bible right I got the Joe Bawa London
course coming out so make sure you know
y'all gonna get that right of course the
meanest Joe Bob is coming out to
adjustable near you yeah but I have a
question first can we roll back the tape
for a second let's get that back on the
screen because your chain says
calculation over everything yeah I see
the groon felt Revisited over everything
so I think you really could change the
letters on that chain or just hand it
over to me oh Mike you know what here
you go my bad bro I guess I gotta take
this off now Jesus come on Robert if you
want to see that but we're on TV right
now
wow so much excitement definitely check
out a James course and a loving scores
if you want to get the wins in with the
white pieces but for now it is time for
some of the players to get the wins in
because let's take a look at the results
that we've got Levon aronian won against
Wesley Stowe our Tamia beat Magnus
Carlsen we see Liam and Fabi ended in a
draw as did Photoshop versus Hikaru the
players are ready to go we've got a lot
of slav our time we have Magnus Carlson
that's the action that we will be
following Magnus how angry is he right
now David he will be furious with
himself because it was all
self-inflicted he allowed all those
tactics to happen he allowed the
momentum to drift against him and he
made the blunder at the end so he knows
that uh he only has himself to blame but
uh three games left today he still has
enough time for sure to fight back and
okay early days vladislava time if he
does tend to dodge the main lines to
dodge anything too Direct in the opening
especially with light and by developing
with the reti kind of English opening
setup he's very flexible I'm not sure
what setup he'll choose but Magnus
either way getting ready to play The
King's Indian or the grunfeld very
Dynamic openings and he might want to
strike back with black but the main
thing for Magnus is not to lose he needs
to stay in this match and uh take his
moment to strike a bit later on in the
day what do we think here is he gonna uh
are we gonna see his anger on the board
you know the thing the hard part is uh
the emotions in chess right now a lot of
times you have to say not even in chess
in life like lots of times your emotions
can affect what you do so if you are
angry here and you just mad and you want
to try to swing at him and of course our
team you have is unfazed I mean he has
the same facial expression all the time
he don't see anything he's losing you
look the same you know he wakes up he
looks the same hey how you doing he
looked the same right always the same so
of course he doesn't have the Motions
don't affect him really much at all so
hopefully Magnus is able to do that and
get it together here and be able to try
to strike back in this game and we know
at the highest level a draw is the most
common result so if your Magma's Carlson
right now you don't want to just go out
all out for a win it's okay to draw with
black he gets white in game three he did
lose the first game of the match with
the white pieces but you do have that
first Revenge you'll have to choose a
different opening because I didn't
really like what we saw from him there
he didn't gain the upper hand but for
Magnus you can't go all in this early I
know he was just playing poker but you
got to relax
yeah I hear you guys but
I have to say I mean the setup that
Magnus has taken just so flexible with
that fan Shadow you know he's not moved
any of the central pawns yet I think it
does show that he's in for a long game
with the black pieces he's not really
looking to go into some long battles he
just wants a position to play yeah
against most opponents Magnus can get
away with trading loads of pieces off
heading into an end game but against
lettuce love Artemis I don't think
that's the recipe for Success well tamif
does have great end game stats I've seen
him out play the best players in the
world in end games uh so Magnus can't go
that route uh meanwhile he's kept all
the pieces on the board it's unlikely we
will see too many trades this early in
the game we see the pawns kind of not
facing off against each other anytime
soon there won't be open lines open
diagonals but I'll tell me if also
choosing the flexible approach and we're
going to see a double fan keto from both
sides both sides putting all of their
Bishops on the long diagonals and the
tension will be postponed to the middle
game are you getting adjustable here I
mean this is actually straight from the
chest of course the one that is is the
grenfield part two in fact from uh
Peter's Fiddler he actually recommends
the double finchito versus uh versus the
double that's exactly what he likes to
do now of course in this situation here
blacks actually plans are C5 and play D5
right after now of course Magnus being a
part of chessable you remember his face
was on on the chessable screen uh many
times for the people that are accessible
users and you see Magnus up there when
you created an account definitely Magnus
is a big fan of Chester has his own
courses there too as well but these are
these lines are very very good C5 and D5
are actually what uh what Peter Fiddler
recommends in these situations just to
make things Dynamic and try to get
something to play for on the board yeah
you're like an encyclopedia thank you
study pretty much every chessable course
out there we know uh the go-to man for
recommendations now but I think you're
right I think that's uh what Magnus
should be trying to do I just have a
feeling he's gonna try and uh kind of
play creepy crawly chess as I call it
she's just going to kind of wait and
wait and then uh kind of keep tension as
much as possible
um he's seen now that ultimate does like
to burn time on the clock does like to
get into time pressure so Magnus if
possible would uh would like to kind of
not trade off any pawns any pieces
anytime soon
yeah we'll have to see such a tense
position yeah
following James Boyne it always
fascinates me so much how accessible
chessable has made training openings
even working on your middle game to
learn from the best in the world Joseph
was made that so easy James you're
dropping names of all these courses we
can learn from the very best in the
world there's never been a better time
to be a chess player Robert absolutely
not because soon we can learn from James
Kenney what more can you say like Coe I
can't wait to buy the Dubai London
course so uh you know we you're right
though we have everybody participating
sharing their knowledge and typically
historically chess has been a game where
people hide that knowledge because
before the Advent of the internet before
engines were a thing people like if I
have it I've worked on this for hours
and hours and hours and maybe nobody
else in the world does but every single
game that's played is goes into the
online database so we have those
resource at our disposal helps many
people from all parts of the world get
better but also means that we can share
because sharing is caring and I think
the Chess World is a better place for it
yeah we'd love to hear your thoughts
Chad on which is your favorite chessable
course there's so much knowledge there
so many ways to improve and to learn
from the best but right now if we've got
the best player in the world playing
this and he currently is trailing his
match against vladislava time we have
now when we think about David playing
for a win in a position
magnus's position is looking a bit too
Katy but is this just him keeping as
many pieces on the board as much tension
on the board yeah I think that's a
conventional chess wisdom if you're in a
must-win situation Magnus isn't quite
there yet but he will want to win uh
then keep peace on the board as you say
Tanya just give your opponent as many
options as possible because the more
Alternatives you give them the more
options more likely it is they'll go
wrong that being said white has done
nothing wrong of course here why it's
developed very naturally so it will be
uh later in the game that Magnus is
going to try and provoke those mistakes
but it's by playing weird and wonderful
moves like this one putting a knight in
the rim looks pretty dim and uh yeah
it's by playing moves like this that
he'll provoke his opponent he might
Force our temu to get over excited and
that's where the mistakes will a bit
later but do we like the look of this
one to me it just looks a bit too
superficial it looks like a provocation
for the sake of propagation not actually
improving Black's position James uh
thoughts on this it's creative I'm a big
fan of creativity create Creator
creative players and just like fun
tactical chess here but Knight A6 of
course chat first off don't try this at
home secondly right it is very creative
the Knight does have to move around
maybe he's going to C5 maybe he wants to
play C6 or C5 put the Knight on C7 maybe
try to push for D5 but of course he is
keeping pieces on the board and that's
what he wants to do to try to create
more chances here because he is down in
the match right now yeah and I'll tell
me if take Center why not advancing
porns and for the first time there is
this clash between the two armies Magnus
is saying okay we can trade off one set
of Pawns but uh yeah that's not
necessarily going to guide the game any
closer to safety for I'll tell me if
what do we think is oh Tim we're going
to be happy with the draw in this game
with white it feels like uh he's played
a very solid setup so far I think you'd
be perfectly happy with it doesn't the
result he's looking for but I don't
think he's a result-oriented player some
people when they're up in the match they
want to put it away our time is like I'm
solid he is that type of player he
doesn't really take too many risks so if
he can keep drawing he will win this
match as long as he doesn't lose and in
this type of position I think he has
good changes to slowly make some small
progress and if Magnus continues to play
accurately like he has thus far I think
the draw would be a likely result and I
don't think our 10 will complain one bit
about it yeah so we've asked the big
questions what result does our time
everyone want the other big question
what do we think of the man bun what do
we think today well you know actually
someone in the chat say he looks like
Samurai but of course he won't have to
swing that sword a little bit harder if
he gonna be a samurai in this match and
it's
an essential knows when to retreat James
so playing with the black piece
doesn't want to take too much risk he
wants to keep things under control and
that's the kind of opening approach it's
not yet the time to go for desperation
or to play Super rash he will have one
more white in this match that is correct
he does have one more white it's going
to be good here right and of course he's
keeping pieces on the board I mean time
is level so far he just can't blunder
like he did before it really it was just
a blunder right and that blows blunders
I mean he took advantage of it so fast
or Timmy have in this case he had four
seconds on the clock it looked like
everything was going in magnus's way and
one blunder cost him the game and the
chest is really hard like that yeah
chess is brutal you can play 40 good
moves and then one bad move and it's all
over now while Magnus Carlsen trades uh
Trails or tamiyav it is Wesley so who is
a point behind in his match against
Levon let's get an update on that one I
do see it is quite a complicated middle
game David what's going on here the
knights in the center looking good is
this pretty even yeah it took me a while
to adapt to try and figure out firstly
how we got here it came from a queen's
camper declined but also the kind of the
shape of the position here the outline
it does look like white pieces have
nicer posts than their counterparts I
love that white knight in the center
it's an outpost it can never get kicked
away evicted by a black pawn I also love
White's light squared Bishop really
exerting its influence on some key
squares and it's going to be hard to get
rid of that piece too however the Black
Knight temporarily is quite well placed
if white wants to kick it back white
will have to weaken his position and
black is the first of the open file the
open C line so it feels like Wesley is
solid enough so solid as I like to call
him but yeah it I would choose white
here I've got to admit that's a good one
baby it's so Sally I guess that I was
like so solid oh so solid oh my God
went over your head there that was nice
by David of course but yeah I mean very
so solid here I mean I'm from Wesley so
flexley so and LeBron here or Lebron is
definitely trying to work his magic with
the white pieces here maybe he could
play F3 or a bishop D3 Queen G4 on the
board okay I like him LeBron I like it I
think actually quite a big decision from
Lavon and it shows that he's not just
playing for equality because he will
likely Kick That Knight away from E4
with his Pawn push that David was
talking about I play F3 to kick the
Knight out but then his Queen is focused
on the king side of the board rather
than where that Rook went to on C8 on
the open file and the key piece in this
position actually is the White Knight on
D4 it cannot be kicked out it also
covers important squares that black
knight cannot jump into B3 that Rook can
never land on C2 with that Knight
sitting there and it's impossible to
kick out so I do think that wycus are
playing on the king side and say I have
a queen and Bishop over there you don't
really have too many pieces defending
that side of the board maybe I can make
some sort of progress how to make that
progress I'm not sure don't ask me that
question but that's up to Lavon aronia
yeah later on not right now you could
certainly imagine a pawn being thrown
forward in typical level and aronian
style and uh yeah he's kind of creative
he'll make that magic happen at some
point if he has the uh the right
circumstances so right now I'm liking
White's position I agree that this move
has to come sooner or later you don't
really want to tolerate the Black Knight
in the center for too much longer but
yeah the more positional the more kind
of solid stable approach the more boring
approach would be to try and trade off a
set of Rooks on the open file but Levon
he's a very ambitious player I think
he'll want to keep tension and go for an
attack if he can and uh yeah Levon
despite the fact a draw would be decent
for him I think he will want to win this
game and really put the nail in uh on
Wesley absolutely I think probably one
of the greatest moves here is uh maybe
even playing Bishop D3 first because the
problem is we want to get this bishop
involved too as well if we can get more
pieces on that side of the board of
course we need multiple pieces I like to
tell students that you need three or
more pieces for a successful attack and
to attack here we need to get pieces we
need more of them the Queen's over there
we got a dark Square Bishop if we can
get that light Square Bishop maybe in
the play maybe get a rook lift right
then you know we have some problems over
here for black side Bishop to D3 is nice
because then when we play F3 we can tuck
and roll with the bishop and put it on
B1 so a long range sniper there all the
way uh you know on B1 they call it a
snake in the grass it's already on the
other side of the board you stab you you
it's gonna bite you right a lot of
poison there the bishop can go slide
back to B1 with a Pawn on F3 too as well
you'll be able to do kind of many things
here we do want to get Rook lifted or
maybe move the Knight around from F3
over to G5 or H4 get the queen of H5 and
we live you make it sound like Checkmate
James and no you're right it does look
pretty scary for black actually
um allowing the white pieces uh to the
king side like this meanwhile he hasn't
gone for this he went for the maybe
lesson vicious approach uncharacterial
uncharacteristic sorry from level on
Iranian but uh that has given Wesley now
the time to start trading pieces in case
you can do it though David now he could
do it now Rook C1 actually is uh maybe
bishop D3 Bishop B1 just to write the
Aesthetics of it nice and now it looks
much more effective because uh this
bishop no longer traps in uh The Rook on
A1 it's on a much better Square now so
maybe similar idea just a different
order from Iranian yeah and James I'm
just looking at all these attacking
tricks that you're talking about with
the queen coming on the H file the
Knight coming to G5 that eight seven
made this is looking good it looks like
attack is going to be built by
lavonaroni and now the other aggressive
player Hikaru Nakamura against
federative I do I do see our revolver it
says that phariseev is doing well I see
a double Bishop Advantage a bishop bear
for Fantasia is that the reason that
white is better in an open position that
to Robert it absolutely is and we Grand
Masters like to call this playing for
two results Federal save as a position
where realistically it doesn't look like
one he can lose even if he makes a bunch
of inaccuracies but he can play for a
win with zero risk you look at the
Bishops slicing across the board White's
Pawn structure also is healthier because
Black's Queen side pawns they are split
they are isolated that means a piece is
required to defend them whereas a Pawn's
best friend is another Pawn so black May
at some point strike forward with one of
those pawns to try to trade but it takes
a lot of time and white would like to
push those Queen side pawns off the
board himself I love this position for
federal save I highlighted before the
games even got underway the federative
has a good record against zakaru in
their recent matchups and I think he's
just learned how to play the half man
half everything else that is Nakamura
correct I mean half man half everything
else the other half we don't actually
know yet and of course with this part I
mean for the save actually I think he
has just kind of figured it out when you
play a player so many times and you lose
so many times I'm sure I mean actually
what was the record rapper from speed
test Championship oh it was like 21-6 or
something I mean Blitz absolutely
blitzed them right so of course fetise
figured it out at this point right now
being just having a recent High record
or a winning record over Hikaru one of
the very few people on the planet to do
that right especially in a short uh time
time frame look at the eval bar just
loving White's position here I mean this
is not looking good for the half man
half for everything else yeah plenty of
options so I want to improve the white
Rooks maybe the white rook in the center
just slides up one square to E2 the
other Rook then is free to slide across
to uh yeah a more active post and
um it's not just the fact that white has
all these kind of strategic advantages
it's also the fact that he's doing well
on the clock and I think that's the key
against someone like Hikaru you can't
lag behind you can't fall behind
um a queen trade imminent now white has
to say yes but uh Bishops the pair of
Bishops especially they do gain in power
the longer the game goes on normally but
uh black is at least active for now what
do we think of this transition uh It's
always important to reassess especially
when the Queens come off I think it's
gonna go just closer to safety I
think yeah stable stable chances now
maybe uh practically especially as we
look at the Fabi Liam League game I mean
it probably was just crushing it but
then he was a draw right so I think this
is actually I mean not it doesn't look
like that game at all it's not down upon
he just has a worse position obviously
because of the Bishops but you know he's
a very active Rook where he can probably
try to attack and Bully these pawns at
some point you have to figure out what
you're going to do with this bishop even
already right now you know so there is
some things you have to worry about a
little bit of initiative here maybe
black has slight initiative you may be
able to get C5 in got to be careful with
A5 but there are some some chances for
black to try to make some things happen
but I like your point David that the
longer the game goes typically the side
with the Bishops has the advantage so
you don't want to get into a forcing
sequence until you're ready because
white has the long-term advantage in a
position like this you have a healthier
Pawn structure your Rook is on this open
e-file can go up the board and H6 played
you can take this Knight you will be
better you probably won't win that game
you shouldn't be winning with opposite
colored Bishops but you get into an end
game where there's zero risk whatsoever
and for federal sale he's had two nice
games thus far against the car where his
hasn't really been worse for a single
move yeah but this is such a big moment
because white has to decide fantasyf has
to decide how does he convert this does
he keep the bishop there does he spoil
black spawn structure and enter with the
Rook to the seventh rank once he's hit
that bishop and it's happening he's
taken his decision you need to try to
convert the advantage how big is this
with the opposite colors it just feels
like it's not going to be enough yeah
I've got to admit I really hate this
decision from uh from vladis Vladimir
sorry Vladimir fadisev just the fact
that he's given up his Bishop pair I'm
very biased I love Bishops but uh it
does feel especially against an endgame
expert like Nakamura as if you've given
him everything he wants suddenly the
white pawns are no longer stable on the
queen side easy targets for the black
Bishop it feels likely at least one set
of Rooks will come off the board despite
the fact all of Black's pawns are pretty
much isolated or doubled they're hard to
attack they can easily be defended by
Black's Bishop uh again with the double
Bishops with the bishop pair keep the
tension just uh the longer the game goes
on the more chances you'll have so why
rush you did the hard work anyway it
feels like he's undone his hard work by
getting a bit Hasty and getting a bit
impatient trading things off yeah now
that the dust has settled in this one
and it just looks like it's going to be
an end game that has a big potential
difference allowed into the draw with
the opposite color Bishop action is on
in the lebanaroni and Wesley so game
Levon looks like he's a man on a mission
today let's bring that one up we see our
eval bar that Levon is in driving seat
in this one as well David wow yeah we'll
just uh get that board up in a second
James was loving that one for uh Lebron
come on LeBron I like it I like I can't
wait to see that game of course with the
aggressive intentions that he has so
many possibilities for him in that
position so we'll get it up in a second
here on this game with the Hikaru and
big fish here which is fairize
um I mean he he definitely just came the
advantage away but I think maybe even
black could play for for even more Rook
B8 and Bishop C3 could have some
problems in it look at this light up
James you're staring at that black
knight right I like this a lot okay that
night about to go night night in a
minute but of course you can go Rook to
D1 I mean maybe I mean he might be even
considering sacking it what do we do
about this H4 Bishop G5 not enough okay
you want to start attacking you want to
rush you know sack first thing later
grandfather Tao says this all the time
right so I mean we do want to do this
but we have to move the Rook first so we
move the rook and then we go for for the
attack yeah this Rook is under attack
The Rook might well just slide across
and uh once the Black Knight Retreats it
might be time uh sooner or later maybe
you have to deal with some threats on
the queen side first but uh live on a
runny look at the potential he has Queen
just uh sitting here nice and pretty
around the black king which is going to
be sweating uh at some point you will be
able to trade off uh one of the best
defenders for black and you will have an
attack but when to go for it I think
that's the big question Robert yeah it's
not easy to decide what to do here
because Rooks are being traded off and
does white want to keep trading I
mentioned earlier the Knight on D4 is
kind of a heroic piece because it covers
the C2 Square so even if the white Rook
decides to slide away the black Rook
cannot infiltrate like you would want to
so that is one piece of good news but
maybe white can also be quick here I'm
actually wondering if white can swap
Rooks off the board and then kind of
find a Knockout I don't really see one I
mean the Knight can hop into C6 that
doesn't look too scary blacks Bishop
will just move back towards f8 and
survive that but Lavon he chose the
earlier option he just keeps the Rooks
on the board he wants the material on
and then to attack later yeah however
this Black Knight does find a way out it
uh will retreat in a second I'm assuming
and there are holes in the white camp
now you've kind of abandoned your queen
side if you do step forward okay we're
seeing this actually on the board then I
think the Black Knight is going to go to
the edge there we go and start harassing
this bishop the bishop can retreat but
suddenly there are outposts for the
black pieces to jump into so it's clear
that Levon has had to give something up
in order to keep pieces on in order to
keep the potential for his attack
Suddenly It's not one-way traffic at
least and earlier we were thinking about
a white attack now white has to be
careful of his Queen side and how
dangerous would an age spawn advance in
such positions be marching down with age
4h5 you're the man James with that age
485 and we live baby come on now that's
this is just another day in the park
another day in the office it is after
Bishop D4 you do want to play H4 H5 take
sack Queen G6 King AJ King F2 Rook H1
making them off the board right if king
cafe bishops
come on LeBron let's go LeBron let's go
Luke Bryan I love it no I think it's a
really good and powerful idea and one
thing to note is this black Bishop on B7
it's really not acting like much of a
bishop it's staring into its own Pawn so
if this Knight Hops and takes the bishop
on B5 for black I wouldn't be surprised
if white takes for the pawn over there
just keeps the domination in the center
that Knight on D4 way outclasses that
Bishop on B7 and if you try to chase
that Knight away with the dark Square
Bishop because the pawn can't touch it
then you're gonna get checkmated like at
some point Black's gonna get made in the
dark squares don't do it right away
because then your queen gets trapped I
just want to avoid that mistake but we
will go for this kind of attack where
the bishop and queen team up together
yeah I got carried away there
eventually white will come in and uh
there's likely to be a Checkmate so uh
let's go back to the players it's
certainly Wesley so under pressure after
levon's great last move and uh Point
down facing an attack
scary times for Wesley so fans gotta say
hi Black's position at all me neither I
definitely like White's position here
with lots of uh lots and lots of um good
good uh prospects for white of course
Knight takes B5 definitely is going to
annoy me a little bit because I do need
this bishop to sack on G6 yeah something
Bishop A6 is understandable too I
understand it's just annoying I have to
get rid of a very strong piece he plays
H5 and then maybe we take and we could
play King F2 and even King G3 if we have
to because the king could be pretty safe
there and play Rook H1 and he could be
done
he could be thirsty gets ready to open
that H file I just love these ideas
James they come so naturally to you is
that how you uh practice with the
calculation for me it's like oh where do
I attack you know I'm I'm just kind of
scouring the whole board and struggling
but uh yeah those uh those attacking
ideas absolutely that's a calculation
work in fact charizable course for that
is improve your calculation or
Grandmaster preparation by Jacob Agar
which is unjustable as well is the
calculation one oh so the positioner
went for your positional players but
definitely the Grand Master of
preparation calculation one yeah no
positional play here exactly you know we
could see a draw of the Bishops keeps
chasing the queen back and forth along
the dark Square diagonal because if
white wants to keep the game going you
have to back your queen up and Lavon
probably not really wanting to retreat
his pieces so badly uh and he did win
the first game with the black piece as a
draw not the worst result in the world
for him yeah I think that's a good point
with the mod situation actually we might
be heading for a repetition because I
also don't see Wesley being too pleased
with continuing the game if not Bishop
he said oh wow
no Wesley once again wow you're gonna
have to chill out right now you're gonna
have to relax H6 I don't believe in it
at all now the engine does of course but
practical chances he's gonna push the
pawn over here when I'm attacking you I
guess he's just saying I have G5 maybe
be able to move the king you don't have
enough pieces says Wesley whoa that's a
really Brave move but it could backfire
certainly Black's gonna have to step
forward even further with his pawns
there's gonna be a bunch of weaknesses
and uh live on he will Retreat his Queen
and then decide how to attack later but
uh maybe we can check out another game
Tanya yeah oh Wesley isn't the only one
who's uh trailing Levon it is Magnus
against artemia where our time we have
leads the match so let's bring up that
game and take a look at how Magnus is
doing with the black pieces well Lots
has happened the center it's a
completely open game very different from
how it started very very different I
just want to note that Liam lay and five
minute karwana they're knotted up one to
one they drew their game uh but in this
one I mean this the evil bar may say
it's 11 level position but it's not
equal it's not a draw look at the
Dynamics here black at some point can
strike with those pawns they're quite
Advanced White pieces don't pass his own
third Rank and the eval Bar says yeah
who cares it's a just a level game right
now so I think both sides will have
their chances Magnus has to be careful
not to press too soon that can backfire
but for artemia he needs to find a plan
yeah he needs to find a plan I'm not
liking his position so much normally I
like playing against what we call
hanging pawns these black Pawns in the
center because you can Target them you
can attack them remove the Defenders and
they might become weak especially the
white Rooks in the on these semi-open
files they can suddenly peer down at
those pawns but here it feels like white
is just cramped and struggling for space
that's why he's offering a queen trade
when you are struggling when you don't
have too many squares to maneuver your
pieces you should try and uh swap things
off at least then the remaining pieces
have more scope but I think Magnus is
going to say no he's going to dodge this
queen trade especially in light of the
match situation and uh again I'll tell
me of where is he going to put his
pieces it's clear what black wants to do
as Robert said throw pawns forward but
uh what is on Tammy going to do also
we've got to mention the clock one
minute again
last time as well but then we saw a big
turnaround you cannot underestimate our
Tamia when he's playing on seconds that
was the big takeaway from round one
David to follow up on your point Magnus
Carlsen with the space Advantage here we
see the flexibility in the Center
thinking that this will not be a trade
makes sense to keep the Queens on the
board and just on that note he says and
give me this oh man this is kind of I
mean really the problem here is as David
mentioned hanging Pawn structure it is
under good to understand the pawn
structure is the skeleton of the game or
it gives you the plans and the ideas
right hanging Pawn structure is
something to to uh to know and actually
when you know about the hanging Pawn
structure you can actually be played
Dynamic right the pawns are weak if you
push one the other one becomes isolated
so you have to be careful which why the
queen trait I really didn't like as much
but I think he didn't like maybe Queen
B2 there after uh and then maybe trading
he had to go Knight E8 or something or
Knight H5 and another trade and the
pawns get weaker as you trade right so
maybe a queen B2 or something was quite
annoying but yeah man it was inching
them like that why what is that A4 it's
a bond sacrifice but it is to get the
central pawn moves moving and how good
is it for white to actually accept this
sacrifice black always has the option to
drive the Rook to it pick up that pawn
it looks like it's going to be too much
compensation Robert yeah and black goes
after them right we keep talking about
Pawns front is another Pawn so isolate
upon that can often be a nightmare but
the good news is the bishop on C3 it
serves as a good defensive piece when
you push that pawn up to A5 so black
while you can go after those pawns you
can you've also cleared the path for
your own pawns you have to look in all
directions full board awareness is
essential in the game of chess so we
don't just give up a pawn and then go
try to win it back you may be springing
free past Pawns of your own and that
could be all the compensation you need
if you're Magus Carlson yeah so for
example if the pawn disappears so what
these two y a pawns they're basically
equivalent to one uh you might well move
your Knights out the way I'm not sure
which direction you go back or forward
but uh now black has a past Pawn of his
own as Robert mentions and uh Magnus
will hope to get this one monitoring
down the board the surprise that you
would what just happened we all are I
mean taking on F6 giving up the bishop
pair just to action replay here he took
this Knight
Grand Masters they love their Bishops
there has to be a reason behind this one
uh this shows no bias at all it looks
like that Bishop was the glue holding
White's position together but he's
removed the black knight from the game
maybe in fear of the night jumping
forward and only now has he taken this
Pawn but these looks so much weaker now
um the rook's gonna go for it later on
suddenly this black C Pawn is going to
start rolling
I've got to say Advantage Magnus Carlson
at least in Practical terms I mean
practical terms look at Artemis clouds
down to 14 seconds left I mean he has to
move and it's not going to be easy just
because there aren't too many pieces on
the board does not make this an easy
situation and the Eva bar keeps getting
lower and lower the bishop pair will
Flex its muscles absolutely it was a
time issue here I think that a bishop F6
move was like oh I got four seconds make
a move and then he made a move and of
course the time as I like to say is you
have to use the time as a piece as well
you get 16 pieces but that 17th one is
the clock and if you're not using it
correctly then you are going to start
making mistakes in time trouble as you
see our Timmy up doing right now yeah
but it is bizarre because I'll tell me
if I've never well very rarely at least
seen him made make these kind of bad
strategic decisions but giving out the
bishop here for no compensation at all
that's an odd one uh normally he makes
decisions that are very well grounded in
a positional sense and now Magnus is
going for those weak points those two
white a pawns they're doomed they're
going to fall off the board in the next
few moves it's a wrap and uh it's all
about whether white can contain the
black shoe and that's a bad move
apparently a big blunder and then you
just take on A4 the d-pawn you can stop
it but you never want to block a p uh
Pawn with a piece you wanna bug with a
knight but if you block with a knight
it's gonna get pinned there's back rank
problems as well I think this position
is miserable for our Timber and he
doesn't have time to think of his next
two moves his Rook C1 just coming in
pinning that night Bishop G5 Advance the
deep bond that Pawn's queening the A4
Bishop defends that D1 squared this
looks absolutely busted for our time
here you're totally right honey I just
don't even think here if your Magnus
Carlsen dropped that black Rook onto the
white first Rank and white is paralyzed
yeah barely move you can't even trade
drugs Rook seedo is impossible you can't
come back with the Rook to D1 The Rook
on C1 will be an absolute monster what
is Magnus thinking maybe it's what's the
alternative well there are actually so
many good moves in this position that's
the problem that's the problem for
Magnus but when in doubt pin and win
just drop that black Rook down to C1 and
that should be game over soon first he
uh attacks the white Rook I don't think
this changes anything he's maybe just
testing our terminal if he's saying okay
you have nine seconds I'm gonna flick in
a little threat did you see it he might
push the pawn right so he just attacked
The Rook you push the pawn the dark
Square Bishop must come across the board
as well into the C3 Square hitting the
rook and the Knight notice they're on
the same diagonal there as well I think
Magnus is playing this perfectly I mean
Bishop takes F6 that was a head
scratcher but since then it Magus makes
it look easy it wasn't as simple as it
appeared and he's just bringing all of
his pieces into the party and it's a
party for one or tell me I'm not invited
love it Robert and uh okay he's still
struggling on he's limping on in this
game uh I'll tell me okay he's at least
broken the pin he's trying to trade off
a set of pieces remember that does guide
you towards safety if you're struggling
uh especially uh if you can get a set of
Bishops off the remaining Bishop will
lose power but Magnus of course won't
trade unless it really suits him he's
looking to cash in on some material and
that might well happen soon
you're thinking about moves like D3
which are possible get that Bishop to C3
there's still a pin on the first rank
Magnus in driving seat and artemia with
just six seconds on the clock this is
the big moment for Magnus Carlsen to
strike back yeah it feels like
self-destruct mode from Magnus in the
first game and then I'll tell him even
this one and that was that moment of
trading that Bishop on F6 that was a
shocking decision even if it was the
clock that made him do it it makes no
sense at all yeah it goes against the
principles right yeah absolutely of
course yeah yeah you want to stay
principled here and he did not he could
have made any move maybe H3 just make a
quick move just to get some time on the
clock here but this is busted game over
start a new one right he's gonna have to
just reset and try to come back in the
next game because Magnus is going to win
this one can you actually go D3 here can
you start pushing the Deep on David yes
Tanya yes I think that's one of multiple
winning moves here the black light
Square Bishop can also drop back hit
that white rook in the center but you
you wrote you're right you called it and
this looks like it's walking into
trouble this move this you can't play
that bro yeah the two white Rooks are
both on dark squares black has a dark
Square Bishop there must be a knockout
blue right now I'm not sure which
diagonal to use they're gonna attack
both your Rooks I can attack your Rook
from every angle that I want and that's
what happens when you give up a Dark
Sword Bishop he goes straight into D4
he's attacking The Rook on E3 he's
trying to kick it away from this past
Pawn on D3 if the Rook slides over the
Knight loses Defender if the Rook goes
up the board then the problem is the D3
Pawn is safe and sound and that black
Bishop will likely go into C3 next I
feel like well white is about to lose
material and the game and Magnus is
gonna be right back in this match not up
one to one and you're right Robert
actually vladislav didn't even struggle
on he resigned he hit the rezzy button
he hit the button yeah we're tied 1-1
Magnus strikes back wow beautiful and
what a game this was with the black
pieces starting so slow but then it
suddenly blew up and a surprising
decision there by our tummy I have to
trade the bishop for the night there was
no looking back from that Magnus with
the Magnus touch as obvious said
squeezing water from Stone but I think
this was very self-inflicted yes this
was self-inflicted and the position
actually where vladislava have earlier
made the mistake this should go in
strategy books why you shouldn't part
with the bishop pair in an open position
here simply take the pawn the position
is fine for white you're still
relatively solid relatively stable he
parted with the bishop pair and suddenly
look Magnus got the pawns rolling and if
we fast forward to the final position it
was actually on the dart squares on the
color complex where he'd gifted the
bishop that Magnus broke through the
final move was Bishop to D4 attacking
this white rook and as Robert said this
Rook is stuck it needs to stay defending
its Knight if it had stepped forward
then multiple ways to win but maybe the
simplest just Bishop C3 you line it up
skewer and that was Game Over Easy win
for Magnus actually there in the end
game yeah a big win by Magnus Carlsen
leveling the score this is where we are
going into round three of day one of the
chassisable Masters Magnus Carlson
vladislav or tamiyev at one one
Vladimir photos here one one two draws
but very Fighting Chess those results
don't tell the story of the match
Fabiano caruana Liam very solid play by
both these players so far also on 1-1
and punches being traded there between a
Wesley so and love on our onion another
match where the score is now level after
Wesley Strikes Back
and with that we will be taking a short
twitch break for our non-subscribers
[Music]
not just division one with division two
and three as well we will be keeping you
updated with all the chats that's
happening in all these three divisions
with big names
and a lot of prize money at stake but
also door points to make it to the
finals of the season and Robert these
are our division two results is that
something that surprises you I'll tell
you what's not surprising is seeing the
14th World Champion Vladimir chronic
winning his match uh but you see some
great results from Nerdy back Abdul
sitarov he takes down anishikiri abusot
the Olympia champion from Uzbekistan the
former world champion he gets it done so
the players we highlighted at the start
of the show they win their matches and I
see 2-2 between kymer and jorg Meyer
that must be going arm again
yeah and uh so many big names I've got
to say Maxim vashilograph getting
through his match pragnananda one of the
stars of last season's Champions chess
tour winning three nil in his match
Daniel duboff going down against Dennis
lazovic so many upsets and uh of course
those who lost their match today will
have another shot but uh yeah so many
decisive games I've got to say only one
playoff that's surprising right now it's
the youngsters the youngsters are
killing they look at Nora back two and a
half over Gary it doesn't even look
right I thought that was a typo then
origin right origin the youngster Dennis
lazovic youngster Vincent kymer neck and
neck youngster right okay and then you
have uh I mean everybody right everybody
here is going uh very uh the kids here
are taking it over right now
wow I mean not a bag against a niche
winning two and a half half that is an
amazing result by another back it's
amazing how easy he makes it look
sometimes and he's Gary one Todd's still
Masters he's been in great form and
nurse
about to say he's angry that was Revenge
I'm gonna say maybe Anish is too busy
with the ceos.com
well he's got his priorities right but
of course the action is still on and
it's not just in division two but in
division three as well take a look at
those names well one big favorite chakra
mamadarov has won his match against Jose
Martinez yeah Jocelyn well known the
chestnut comp Community we also have an
FFL a famous Legend in gotta komski he
takes down his opponent rasulo but we
see some really elite players in
division three way Yi are you kidding me
in division three what's that about and
then we see that all the way down to the
bottom players who are in division one
of the air things Masters uh gukash ring
a bell to you he lost to David Anton
that's a super Grand Master matchup in
the first round of division three That's
How Strong the Champions chess tour is
we have it I can't get my head around
this I mean we're talking about division
three and take a look at the bracket at
the matchups the players who are playing
and this is what I love about this new
season and the new format we've got all
these big fights big names playing in
division three as well but right now it
is all eyes on back to our division one
as we go into round three action is
about to start the results are on we've
got
Magnus Carlsen who did level his score
against artemiev for this round three we
will be keeping our attention on Wesley
so against Levon now this has been a
match where they've been trading punches
two decisive games what are you
expecting from the third round I don't
know what to expect how can I I mean
they're winning games left and right
it's back and forth between these two as
a class of styles Lavon he likes these
kind of artistic positions well see he
is like I'm a scientist here so we're
not gonna get into Coldplay songs but I
do feel like Wesley so he's feeling good
right now after that Victory I love it
James ART versus science who wins uh you
know we're gonna go with the art every
time okay LeBron oronian that's what I'm
going with the creativity and the fun
stuff but this ain't creative at all
right now I'm gonna tell you right now
okay maybe a little bit now we get to C5
in there so it does was expecting
something a little bit more sharper here
but this is pretty good of course so far
we gotta isolated pawns so we'll see
what happens maybe Knight C6 oh wow
trade in Queens yeah I'm about to go to
sleep I'm gonna go to sleep right now
this is what they call Berlin of 1d4 it
heads straight to the end game Black's
King is misplaced black has a slightly
kind of fractured Pawn structure but
everything else is relatively balanced
this one's been worked out to death
almost the top players have figured out
how to draw this as black but has
Le'Veon done his homework does he know
his stuff Wesley taking a solid approach
with white and maybe not a surprise we
should mention black has won both games
so far in this matchup so maybe Wesley
with white he's saying okay it's
actually a disadvantage I'm just gonna
get out of this game let me move on to
the next one
yeah and the one player who's burned
this position with black to death is
actually Wesley saw himself this is an
opening that he plays so he definitely
knows what he's doing coming to David's
Point Robert that Levon has to be sure
because black still has to navigate to
complete equality in these end games
yeah so many of the top players have
used this opening successfully uh your
good friend and compatriot Gujarati he
plays this we've seen many games
the list goes on and on but the key to
this position is while currently black
is up a pawn those are double isolate
Pawns in the center in front of the
black king and that King has already
moved and it just moved again so you
can't Castle will you find true shelter
where white has the pair of Bishops
that's a critical question but
oftentimes white has to relinquish the
pair of Bishops just to get the pawn
back and we may see some Obstacle of
Bishops in this game and that often
leads to positions where they're quite
balanced yeah the fact that Wesley so is
thinking right now makes me uh just a
bit wary a bit uh skeptical that he's
actually come armed with a big idea it
does feel like he just wants to take the
sting out of uh levon's sales and it
does actually in terms of Chess Karma
tend to backfire if you play for a draw
with weight you often get punished but
uh yeah we can't blame him it's been
such an emotional day for both of them
so far such a roller coaster that uh a
timeout a solid game wouldn't go amiss
so okay he brings his Bishop out I'm
expecting blacks Rook actually to slide
over two squares to defend that night
you don't want to allow White's Bishop
to take uh on C6 and break the structure
even further but uh yeah Levon he'll be
wanting to be as accurate as possible
there we go Rook C8 on the board very
logical play by laughter brings the real
card onto the C file x-raying that King
Wesley moves sidesteps with that King to
B1 now well this is going to be a slow
grind and end game it's a solid approach
by both these players something that we
haven't seen in the day so far uh I
think we're gonna come back to this but
there's one game that's heating up and
we're gonna jump to that one it is
Hikaru Nakamura against a fantasy of
currently a level score with two draws
it looks like this one hikaru's got an
advantage I see an H Pawn and I know
James loves it yeah that's me at H Pawn
for me all day every day baby okay H4
what is this opening first uh some type
of King's Indian attack I think it looks
like right we have a Pawn on E6 Knight
to G5 looks good but my Bishop okay is
nothing there yet so we have to build up
this attack with Knight H2 the Knight G4
stuff but it's not there I might even
play Pawn G4 at some point Knight H2 put
the pawn on G4 go G5 move the Knight I
mean all kinds of ideas I even like to
think cattle the bishop there's a
weakness on E6 I like white chances all
day oh you're so aggressive James and uh
Hikaru also plays a very ambitious move
he plays C4 he's trying to break this
structure if black commits now if for
example black trades off then in the end
game later on he will be saddled with an
isolated Pawn if he steps forward
however yes you gain space but there's a
nice juicy Outpost for whites nights
later in the game you could imagine one
night coming forward the other night
maybe uh centralizing as well and black
can never challenge for this beautiful
Square enter backward Pawn as well you
also mentioned there James some ideas of
actually going for this Pawn in the near
future definitely on the cards I'm
liking white too I'm gonna be James the
worst nightmare here I'm gonna say what
if black takes this Pawn on C4 and then
trades the queen
bro why you gotta do that right you know
it's funny because you I'm a little
worried about you now I'm sitting next
to you I'm feeling all these tactical
skirmishes that you want to see on the
board so I'm like I don't want to fight
James Cancer you kidding me you see
those biceps over here so I'm like let's
trade those Queens in federal Sav well
he plays a calm move he's like let's
just go H6 let's just chill let's keep
James happy this Queen stay on the board
yeah Queen stay on the board that's good
because I'm definitely not trying to
trade those Queens you don't play the
Kings Indian attack just to trade to
Queens of course but of course the
Hikaru is half man half of everything
else he can do whatever he wants in this
life and still win the game right now of
course uh I'm not trying to trade it at
all really the Queens but it is possible
to also have maybe a bishop H3 here to
attack E6 is very weak right maybe
bishop to D2 or queen to C2 anything
other than trading agreed anything other
than that someone needs to go back and
clip that did you see Hikaru you
mentioned trading Queens he just walked
out he just got out of his chat I just
left and as soon as he saw that the move
wasn't played the quiz are still on the
board he came back now he's more
interested in the position and I like it
James just get that White Queen off the
defile avoid that tension avoid any
trades and uh it's still very tense of
course but I like Hawaii's chances it
feels like that black E6 Pawn that we
highlighted a few moments ago is uh
maybe the key to the position it's a
weakness eternally and I just want to
bring out what I saw in our chat that
this competition is brutal and I
couldn't agree more with it we did the
other things Masters but just even the
score lines so far it just shows how
evenly matched and stacked it is stop
the bottom gems absolutely of course uh
I mean even though division three like
that's division three three bro what are
you talking about right everybody is so
strong there right so in a double
elimination format I mean really if
anything is up for grabs anything
yeah remember some Grand Masters didn't
even get to division three some really
elite players so that's how stacked it
is that's how lucky we are with this new
format really inclusive uh kind of
making chess making the chess career
more viable for everyone hopefully
inspiring the young players the young
viewers out there to keep studying keep
improving to maybe try and qualify for
the event but uh yeah we're just blessed
and uh to be treated to this Feast of
Chess hmm
wow in this last move 8-6 and we see
Hikaru having a think and finally he
goes through the move Knight H2 Robert
where's this Knight headache because the
g-force square is still guarded what are
the plans in this position well whether
my hook or by crook I think James wants
to see that attack and maybe the night
goes to H2 to push the pawn up the board
that's where it is covered and you may
want to use the H6 Pawn as a hook to
open up that flank I don't really
believe in it and one thing I want to
know because this is an unusual opening
at the highest level is the hikara
Nakamura may play too much chess and I'm
not saying that for all you viewers calm
down I know you love watching him stream
that's not not advocating for him to
stop doing that but that means in terms
of preparation that when you play so
much your opponent is never surprised by
what you do when you prepare for a card
Nakamura you prepare for everything
under the sun yeah and so when he plays
a king zinni attack you're like yeah
he's done that 7 312 times before I'll
be the 7313 time right remember that
number correctly yeah
yeah you can't surprise your opponent if
all of your games are out there like
able to be researched in the database uh
poor Hikaru trying to come up with new
ideas trying to learn all those openings
uh big brain I've got to say but it's
still on tap James that Queen trade is
it gonna happen oh my goodness I hope
not man because he could just take that
boy and then I mean yeah okay white is
is better but I mean it's Queen trade I
mean it's boring I play king's Indian
attack and now I'm in an end game like
that never happens King's in the attack
and in game you never put in the same
sentence if you look at all Bobby
Fischer's games they were none of those
were in games in King's Indian attack
having this one it's gonna be uh
hopefully doesn't trade I see fantasy if
he's reaching out for for the mouse
let's have a deal if D takes E4 Bond
catches Queen captures trades we switch
games
wow you're just making James happy over
here let's go I played the end game
fascinating and I think for everybody
watching you know we're joking around
here on set but end games are of
critical importance I think for newer
players they don't get into so many end
games because the game ends with a
tactic with a sacrifice with the
Checkmate but end games hour of critical
importance so we may see some very
instructive play here things that you
should just point out just like visually
speaking is that blacks pawns on the
queen side those A5 and C5 pawns two
squares apart they're on dark squares
some of the light squares will be
vulnerable so you just want to pinpoint
all the nuances in a position and we are
seeing that portrait is a good decision
good decision by federal save I really
like what he's doing here and he
actually didn't trade the Queens you can
agree all right but he's going forward
he's opening up his light Square Bishop
right let me throw from it
let's go let's move on I want to keep
talking I was like oh nobody will notice
if I say that
wishful thinking we're still thinking
that the Queens are still on we signed
on the deal Queens have been traded with
Robert to take your point forward you're
absolutely right it feels like a
queenless middle game and there's still
everything to play for here that last
move is is pretty aggressive by black
you know you push that pawn forward
fantasy of looking to activate the
bishop on C8 bring that out e-pawn will
advance further down to E4 also
controlling that default Square things
look good for here for now for feather
save but we will stick to the facts that
we made Queens have been traded we will
move on to our next game Fabiano caruana
taking on Liam Li that match is also
level let's bring it up David wow and uh
actually it's almost Deja Vu come to
their first game of the day where look
at that white knight it's threatening
that black V7 point he's not gonna
blunder it again shortly no he defends
and uh okay Fabiana re-roots his Knight
I've got to say I love White's position
just look at the central control yes
you've got a set of doubled pawns on the
e-file but they control every important
Square in the middle there you're able
to kind of switch your focus to the
queen side to the king side imagine the
white Rook stacking up behind each other
on the f file to me it looks beautiful
but where's the Breakthrough that's the
big question Liam is Rock Solid right
now barely any weaknesses the Black
Knight will cover any weaknesses if
there are any and uh yeah Fabiano the
question the onus is on him what to do
next you need a plan this is all about
planning long term strategy uh again
maybe not as fun as those attacking
types of positions that we like to see
but Fabiano he knows how to work his
magic here and I think he's the favorite
definitely definitely think he's a
favorite I think maybe you double the
Rooks first and then um well I mean you
have to figure out how you defend the
spawn he could try Queen E7 or something
maybe give up two for the queen but I
don't believe that that is actually the
greatest it could work but maybe it goes
Knight d8 or h8 or H6 maybe Knight H6 or
something like that but we have to
figure out how we get you know double
the Rooks right and the key here is
maybe if he's able to play the Knight on
C5 maybe play D4 at some point and open
some things that we may have some
chances here but I mean it's difficult I
do like white here but black is kind of
solid here we don't have more like the
materials level we have the same in
pieces so it's really hard to really
create anything right now without making
some type of concessions ourselves yeah
it's so weird it looks like black is
super passive this queen these Rooks on
really terrible squares blocked in just
purely defensive but
they're actually doing a good job of
holding the white Army at Bay so
um yeah this one's very tense he played
the move you predicted that James just
shuffling across with the white rook and
question to Liam okay he defends by
centralizing his Knight still early days
I guess in this one it's uh going to be
a very stodgy battle and the night goes
back where it came from hoping to grab
that pawn on B7 but lightning won't
strike twice yeah I think he's just
trying to keep black Frozen because
there's not really an idea in this
position for them like he's saying your
attack my F6 Pawn I defend it my B7 Pawn
is under attack I need to keep that
Defender I can't push that beep on
because the Queen the Knight are teaming
up on the queen set over there so let me
right now he's playing defense I'm not
sure if he's ever going to be capable of
putting into offense with a pawn push
and I often say the side that controls
the pawn breaks is the side of the
avenge I don't see any pawn breaks for
either side that's why I think it's
quite level very nice yeah actually the
more I think about it you're right
Robert you can't really push any pawns
for white without creating weaknesses
yourself and that would be a very risky
strategy for Fabi to just kind of throw
everything forward that might well
backfire I couldn't the professor Liam
just because firstly he's the head of
Webster University chess team but also
just his approach he's so scientific
he's very very careful with how he kind
of handles things defense things and I
did see a bit of a headshake there from
Fabi I think maybe he's frustrated that
he hasn't got any more out of his
promising opening position uh Tanya are
you excited with the development of this
one we wanted to jump over from that
queenless position but this one's even
more even slower
it's definitely slow but one thing that
strikes me is how Fabi is chosen the
same opening and the same setup as is
game one well why fix what's not broken
it got him it got him the point and here
we see the double Pawns in the center
two sets of double pawns that Knight on
A5 hitting on B7 this is going to be a
slow grind though David uh I think again
it's the kind of position where it feels
like if anyone will push it will be
white yeah I I did make a chessboard
course on the art of grinding but even
here I don't believe in white sir Thanks
James yeah I do have that one was of
course on Tick Tock or on chessable
it was a chessable course it was with
Magnus Carlton it was more an endgame
grinds how to screen out those extra
half points okay got it got time for
grinding Robert but um yeah uh even me
here I would be struggling to see
White's potential to grind this one out
I definitely don't see any uh active
plans for either side Liam is reduced to
just waiting he's going to shuffle his
Queen back and forth Fabi just slowly
inching forward giving his King some
breathing space it's hard to get excited
about this position I've got to admit uh
maybe we can switch check out some of
the action elsewhere
let's take a look we've got action on
everywhere and as you said David in this
in this position it is going to be a
long game currently looks like both
players are doing fine let's take a look
at the world champion against our Tamia
Magnus Carlton did strike back in game
two game three is on with our Tamia well
this time better time management by our
time you have
for now
we've got to add that on because later
on he might well tank we've seen him
freeze a couple of times just spend six
seven minutes on just one move but it
looks like he's got a healthy position
I've got to say it looks very balanced
we look at the pawn structure almost
symmetrical again we're going for those
fearing ketos uh seems to be the theme
of this match and yes white has access
to the open file but that could be
challenged Anytime by the black Rook on
that c line I'm expecting black to uh
offer some trades at some point
in general I tend to prefer white here
just because
I don't know I it feels like with the
open file with an extra Tempo that you
start the game with it feels like you're
first with any complications with any
action but black is Rock Solid I'm a big
fan of that actually too as well yeah
black is uh Rock style here but I do
like the fact that my Bishops are active
I can even play something like Bishop A3
at some point or maybe try to get uh
obviously uh we can't get the file now
but if we can maybe play a G4 is very
committal but trying to get you know
McQueen C2 Queen C7 take the seventh
rank as much as possible or if we can if
it is possible but it's kind of
difficult maybe Queen E2 Queen B5 right
we have the B5 Square seems pretty weak
there
um so we do have lots of possibilities
and activity I think division 105 is
just there it's just there not really
doing anything of course we have lots of
activity I think from White yeah I think
your point is well taken it's a game of
squares not a game of captures at the
moment right and that can be difficult
for a lot of chess players because they
think I want to check check check me and
I want to take takes takes takes as we
know a certain streamer likes to say but
in this type of position it's all about
maneuvering and you see Black's last
move Rook T8 I'm not really sure where
that Rook is going uh what is his next
move if you gave black a free turn I'm
not entirely sure what would happen next
and that's the nature of a position like
this quite close no side can easily
create a pawn break any Pond push is
committal in its own way I think it's
just going to be a tough maneuvering
battle between these two wow and David
that last move Rook to year is it
potentially ever ever going to threaten
the pawn advance in the center F6 E5 or
is that just too much for black it feels
like too much right now at least Tanya
but uh I agree maybe he's just hinting
to Magnus he's saying okay that idea is
on my radar to throw some of black
Central pawns for it later to evict that
white knight kick it away but he's just
keeping his options open yeah it's
always psychological I've played I'll
tell me up so many times he always
crushes me online especially in Blitz
but over the board I've played him a few
times too and he asks questions that's
the key with him he's saying okay you've
got five sensible moves which one are
you gonna pick I'm going to hint that
I'm going King side then I'll switch
I'll go Queen side and he's very kind of
he's like a spider in a way he's just uh
creeping around you know you never know
where he's at where you've got him but
yeah he keeps tension and he's very very
calm we've seen him beat Magnus even
with two seconds left on his clock so
okay Magnus locks down the queen side
fully I think clumping down on squares
James mentioned that the White Queen
would love to get to the B5 Square later
white has taken control over that one
but yeah still yet to see that's uh that
kind of action that we're all craving
right now at some point this position
will explode it will open up but who is
going to take the first step and okay
the black queen now activating herself
nice move that was a nice move that was
a very nice move highlighting the fact
that B3 is weak now you can't really
move the queen go Queen E2 I'm going to
take that pawn and look at you at the
zoom camera all crazy you've just
literally dropped one right so B3 is
definitely weak here now I can even
bring a rook to the file my Bishop is
strange on F5 so maybe I'll take with
the bishop but I'd also could take with
the Rook um obviously too as well so
yeah it's definitely an annoying move to
face for for white yeah it reminds me of
this thing right we always hear about it
in chest that pawns don't move backwards
and every pawn move has its own set of
consequences Magnus decided to stop
black from advancing his own Pawn down
the A5 but in the process meet the B
Pawn week and our time we have
immediately jumping in with that Queen
connecting the Rooks there are always
threats in the center but right now he
ties down White's Queen on D1 making
sure that Magnus cannot complete his
development and connect his Rooks yeah
this game is looking quite level in a
game that's already concluded with
equality was the game between Wesley so
and Lavon Ronan it says one half one
half but there were actually blows
traded in the first two games now we see
a solid draw in game three nothing
excited James for your sake we won't
even look at it I just want to let
everyone know that game is drawn they're
getting closer to that lovely Armageddon
with bidding yeah I think it's uh I
think it's the most likely result right
now uh we called it we saw the opening
Quince came off nah move on it's gonna
be a draw and that did inevitably happen
these two these players these top
players they kind of cancel each other
out they neutralize each other if it's a
level position it's unlikely either side
will go wrong so uh very balanced that
match so far I don't know who the
favorite is Levon does have white
however in the fourth rapid game of the
day and uh in this one Magnus has
activated his Bishop again hard to get
too excited especially after this last
move by black neutralizing the pressure
on the open C file things are going to
start coming off the board flying off
the board trades That Eminem it but
David there is a threat Knight C3 you've
got to watch out for this night jump hit
that Queen the queen doesn't have a
great spot to defend the B3 Pawn so
suddenly there's a little bit of poison
in the position that Magnus needs to be
careful about this is true I
underestimated this every move does have
its consequences and I liked magnus's uh
decision to put the white dot Square
Bishop on the A3 Square looks like a
nice diagonal but suddenly there are
holes that he has abandoned and just to
point out uh tania's secret uh hidden
planner Knight C3 nice Outpost for the
Knight supported by the black rook and
it would be sad if your Magnus Castle to
retreat your Bishop just to cover this
Square I don't think it's going back
maybe maybe he assumed that the trade
could happen and he could start grabbing
pawns but this one gets really sharp and
the Black Knight might just start
jumping in everything will Spring to
life let's go back to the players yeah
big moment yeah big moment in this one
while things are heating up a bit Magnus
is taking a thing while Magnus decides
what to play let's take a quick look at
Hikaru Nakamura taking on a fantasy of
another big match and wow look at that
center with those three nights what on
Earth is going on here these nights is
what he calls it on his own channel
these nights is what Hikaru says and
look at those nights right there in the
center they look great in fact now of
course there are no Queens on the board
so it's definitely boring but at the
same time of course it's not that boring
there is some activity the nights are in
the center the pawn on E5 is quite weak
as well I mean white definitely has some
good chances here but black is active so
active you know the great night on D4
right so it's just about who is going to
be able to make something out of this
okay there's so many nights on the board
which one's your favorite I can't even
tell they're all so strong right right
uh I can't even see a productive move
for white it's so locked up so blocked I
don't think you ever want to trade off
Black's Knight in the sense it'll just
be replaced by an equally strong pawn
and yeah maybe it's just a kind of
status quo position you just both tiptoe
around neither side trying to disturb
too much neither side really willing to
open it up on the opponent's terms and
uh okay he steps back one of the nights
is gone from the same but he's opened up
you have to be very very careful here
because that Bishop on G2 it's sniping
across the board that the bishop in
front of the white king is very very
dangerous that B7 Pawn is in its sights
and if it can actually grab that pawn oh
boy two Rooks are under attack at the
same time so Hikaru he's been
maneuvering if we just think about this
structurally black has an isolated Pawn
the center of the board White's Pawn
structure is healthier black has these
active Knights the 94 is a monster it's
the maybe the best piece on the board
but the Knight on G4 is kind of awkward
and maybe it can be kicked at some point
so I'm starting to like some of the
elements of this position for white the
Contour of it seems to be favorable for
akaru and I like his maneuvering I think
he's put his pieces on great squares
yeah he has uh for sure there Robert
okay and a bit of a sad move to have to
play for better safe but it does bring
it back to your first point that this
Pawn needed to be defended so uh it
doesn't signal good things forfeit
itself if he has to take time out for
such a defensive move but maybe it was
necessary
wow and we see a bishop trade has been
offered oh there should be four
Fellowship immediately blitzes out the
move G6 so he says I will trade better
on my terms you take that Bishop I will
get a Side Pawn to the center of the
board and control the E4 square that
would be a very favorable trade for
black Hikaru not looking too happy with
his position that won't Rook be it also
hints at a potential B5 at some point
breaking open the position yeah that may
look bad for the pawn structure you'll
get two isolated pawns over there but
you're getting the activity and we know
chess players they love activity they
might even give up upon that sort of
pieces are active I like the way Federal
save is handling this the position the
dynamic is changing and yet he responds
instantly he is not going to go down the
clock against akar Nakamura Hikaru used
the clock as his biggest weapon he wrote
the book literally on bullet chest yeah
he wrote that book I don't know a decade
ago and the point is for hikarus he
loves to use that clock as a piece and
certain James Cameron yourself come on
Robert has speaking nothing but make it
this man a raise
right that's crazy but yeah this is it's
really a difficult situation I mean from
both sides here I like white just
because maybe we have the activity I
mean obviously we have the first move to
a little bit of tempo here and there
right but A4 is weak e5's weak and uh we
do have some chances uh but our pieces
don't look the greatest I mean at least
not a one dozen the Brooklyn A1 doesn't
look as good the Knight D5 is fine I
mean maybe we want to draw I think he
probably is okay with going to the blitz
or the Armageddon here but I mean even
there he lost like what the last five
games to fetise so there's no Advantage
there either right now so I mean really
he's just trying to make anything work
maybe F3 F4 at some point but I was
trying to uh move forward that's and he
needs to use the clock a little bit
better too as well he's down a little
bit of time yeah it does feel like his
type of position Hikaru there's not that
much risks the stakes are higher for
black as you guys mentioned there black
is the one with actually more weaknesses
so if things open up then it's more
likely Black's Position will fall apart
than whites and Hikaru he's very good uh
now that he's a bit older he plays so
much as we see we Place hundreds of
Blitz Games every day he's mastered the
art of grinding right and uh yeah if if
he gets given the opportunity he's going
to try and massage this Advantage slowly
step his pawns forward slowly improve
his pieces and if feathers they have
stuck unable to get active then one more
traffic later and you say a lot of
slowly is that David uh while I see our
bar has really quickly moved on to favor
our time yeah what or not is going on in
that one we will come back to this it is
a very fascinating end game but for now
let's rush back to Magnus taking on our
tummy a bit
yeah black might be slightly better but
not that much there's still game on it's
you've got a bishop there but that
Knight on E5 is nice the Knight on E5 is
nice but maybe later it will get kicked
back black also has easy access to the
open file the only open file of the
board we mentioned earlier it was quite
an important one the black Rook at some
point can Shuffle over attack that White
Queen kick her away and of course the
bishop pair long term not right now but
long term is in his pocket I'll tell him
if he lost the last game because of the
bishop pair he might win this one
because the bishop here later on
question what happens to the B Tree Pawn
as well where right now the bishop on F5
is attacked so you've got to fall back
but you've got to find a way to defend
that uh that pawn on B3 the queen on the
C5 can't stay there for too long black
intends to go Rook C8 next it's looking
like black is having all the fun right
this is a position where artemia he can
just maneuver he can take over the only
open file on this board he has the
bishop here remember he lost the
previous game because he handed that
advantage to Magus Carlson and right now
with Magnus striking forward with G4
that can backfire your king may find
himself a bit Airy and without
protection yeah well I I saw a chat and
I've got to bring that up for a panel
vote Magnus looking like Nepal yes or no
David
I like it he's channeling his inner Yan
uh Jan doesn't have the man bun anymore
we know where all the hair went but yeah
I'm liking it either way he's got his
own style these top players you know
they're all stylish in their own way oh
man that's funny the man bun there of
course yeah the Magnus spun the mag I
saw magnepo there right from somebody
like mac nipple that's pretty good their
chat keep them coming
wow yeah enough I'm gonna see in just
five in just a couple of days we'll be
fighting for the world championship
again against England who by the way
happens to be the Reign accessible
Masters champion okay yeah he won that
title last year last season on the tour
ding uh yeah in really impressive
fashion I've got to say but uh yeah he's
taking a break from the tour now to
focus on a world championship we can't
blame him for that I heard you had a few
words with him Tanya recently and uh yes
yeah that will be revealed later in the
week we will be bringing you some
exclusive uh footage with our interview
again with ding before he left for the
world championship match it's definitely
something we're all very excited about
but for now G4 has been played and I saw
someone said trapped Bishop well the
bishop does look like it's got some
squares you can move it back to E6 but
it does make me think why is our time we
have taking so long here he does this
we've seen it before today already he's
tanked he's Frozen and he spent half of
his time before this he had five and a
half minutes now he's only got around
two and a half so he spent nearly half
his time on this one move is it worth it
we've got to see we've got to wait on
his decision now there is maybe an
argument for taking that white knight
off the board now trading it off just
because the black light squared Bishop
sorry would be able to jump into the
position it would get access to even
more squares but that feels committal at
some point you just have to decide you
have to say okay it's not clear that
I'll get an advantage that way anyway
let's keep the tension let's keep the
Bishops let's keep the game going but uh
he just needs to decide there's no right
or wrong here he's got multiple options
as long as he keeps his Bishop safe but
flagislava
yeah his time Advantage is gone and I
think Magnus is very happy is he is he
thinking about putting in a rook C8
Robert here yeah I think that's what
he's calculating I was looking at his
eyes because for a moment I thought he
was frozen he's Frozen in terms of not
making a move but I thought maybe his
camera went out that happens in these
events you disconnect and you could lose
but he does play Rooks here that's what
he was calculating and that's what he
needed to figure out Bishop C5
interposing the attack on uh the White
Queen by attacking the black queen as
well and now if the black queen moves
you lose your Bishop but at some point
David's idea with Bishop the black
Bishop in front of the king taking that
Knight in the center their Pawn on D4
might be overloading it's protecting
minor pieces in both directions it's
gonna have to capture uh one and then
lose the other yeah the white porn
wishes it had two moves here in a row
two lives but yeah it looks like you
actually have to remember move this
black Bishop from the board there are
too many threats the black Bishop for
example taking this Pawn next move
threats along the C file with some nasty
pins but if the bishop is captured as
Robert mentions the white Bishop force
and I think our teammate was trying to
evaluate this end game he's looking five
six moves into the future he's trying to
guess maybe whether he has any winning
chances here to me it looks pretty
balanced but he is the one with the more
active Rook so maybe but uh yeah he's
looking deep deep into the position
maybe it was worth that time investment
if this position happens on the board
but does Magnus have options that's the
question does for example this queen
tried to get out the way I'm not sure
where it goes it definitely feels like
this pin and the tension on the White
Knight is too much for white to Bear you
have to enter that Rook end game but
then it's uh very much likely to head
towards a draw so uh Magnus now coming
to terms with that one minute on the
clock against one and a half this one is
going to be a scramble but we are
heading towards that end game the bishop
needs to be captured now Magnus can't
really keep the tension he's playing
with fire dicing with death if he does
ignore that capture and there we go
Queen's off as well most likely and
we're in the end game now two sets of
double point this is a strange structure
like look at the two pawns I mean like
two sets of double bonds F5 F3 and then
E3 and E5 like you never get a position
like that so of course there are chances
from both sides lots of weaknesses of
course if you go for my pawns I'll go
for yours says Magnus and with this Pawn
on F6 being a nice wedge Pawn here you
know you can get some problems there's
some back rank problems in there and
maybe I could even get a rook to the
seventh rank if you allow me to get this
d-pawn you'll be in some trouble here so
maybe most likely a draw not trying to
take any concessions here yeah but this
last move important by Magnus as you
mentioned uh just creating that wedge
just creating some counter play Magnus
the big risk for him was just being
passive going defensive with this rook
and the black Rook kind of getting
active attacking pawns the black king
could have come into the game but now
that black king is going to take an age
to uh find a good Square yes Magnus has
weak points but the white Rook will soon
get active looks balanced well this
looks like a level end game but both
players have to be careful with just a
minute and on the clock let's take a
look at our other board which is getting
super exciting as Fabiano caruana takes
on Liam that King on G7 that long
diagonal Queen on A1 this is tactics
everywhere The Rook is hanging what do
you do as black but there's a fork on E2
that's the exact point Black's last move
was actually putting the rook in the
Queen's path If This Were bullet maybe
Fabiano would take that Rook on C3 and
then lose his Queen immediately because
the Knight comes into E2 with check to
the king and check to the queen
simultaneously down goes the queen so I
think that Fabiano he's now looking this
like whoa what's going on here do I have
to also watch out for a rook C1 check if
black had a free move that would be it
because then you win the queen again
with this Knight Fork on E2 so things
are crazy in this position and Bobby the
eval Bar says it's in his favor he
doesn't know that he has to calculate on
his own and you could take the Knight on
G3 after Rook G3 black has David an
intermediate Queen E5 don't take that
Rook back on G3 because then the C3 Rook
does hang it looks like tactics
everywhere or if that bar says there is
a blowout here David what's the move I
see six oh James nice uh I'm not sure I
think it looks strong Knight takes porn
but it's so complicated right now you
are attacking this queen
whoa Rook F7 but but he gets the queen
this one gets complicated because now
look at the current position it's rook
and Knight versus queen but this king is
trapped you've got to be really careful
for checkmates and as Robert points out
a huge threat on the board and I was
like what about Roxy one check before
that Rook was pinned to the king so I
was like oh don't you win the queen back
on the spot The Rook you try to move it
it can't do that the King was in the
other line uh from the queen on A1 so
David I'm with you though this is
looking scary for white in a blitz
scramble you get checkmated but I love
that move King up too great move buy
five in the car one of the king is going
to continue up the board yeah finally it
can breathe clean air fresh air and if
you keep your king safe with white you
should be winning the queen will
overpower the black Rook at night
eventually but uh that was tactical mess
it feels like Fabiano navigated it well
but it took him time and still some work
to be done well he does pick up to be
three Pawn so if you just do a material
count black isn't doing that bad but it
looks like all the pawns on the queen
side are going to fall one after the
other Lego House of Cards Queen E5 I
like it C7 Falls with a check B7 will be
hanging uh black can currently pick up
the B4 Pawn as well
but uh I guess he just wanted to get
coordinated with his pieces the Knight
now acting as a blockader Defender yeah
this won't last too much longer I have a
feeling uh Fabiano just why not be
greedy when in doubt take bones and uh
the White Queen will easily deal with
black spawns whereas the black Rook the
Black Knight are far less agile
versatile pieces so uh it will most
likely the white B Pawn cost the life of
one of those two black pieces if one
should be game over any moment now wow
Fabiano go on on the brink of taking a
match lead with the win on this one he
has that very active Queen and more
importantly that b-pawn rolling down the
board the a pawn cannot go far down with
a check on B to the pawn can get to A2
but will be hard to go
um ahead more than that he first
sidestepped any check working F3 but
action is heating on on the other boards
this looks like it's going to go fabi's
way let's quickly go to the Hikaru board
wow there is a lot going on there
Fellowship in a winning position let's
bring up Hikaru Nakamura versus
is he getting checkmated look at that
white king my goodness it's fighting
against a black Rook a black knight a
black king and if it's not Checkmate
Hikaru is going to win so the evaluation
Bar says yes but where is The Knockout
blue white pawns are running so black
has to do something now but black can
stop it by threatening a Checkmate
because the Rook sliding in front of the
king you deliver that critical check but
I'm gonna say wow he says not yet but
what he is going to do is if that white
pod pushes forward right now you
actually are able to start by giving a
check on G2 the king slides to the
corner Knight F2 check this is all
happening right now the black king will
take it and The Rook covers the pass
Pawn you do not get to promote and black
is winning this game oh my goodness and
he's shaking his head here and it is
again he's winning again unbelievable
this is an unbelievable streak I've
never seen anything like this from any
player on the planet to be able to beat
Hikaru in all of these games look at him
he's he's frustrated he's angry oh my
goodness this is crazy this is like what
set seven six games in a row now well
they drew these two but yeah it's like
wow yeah the guy looks very frustrated
and that's it he's smiling because if he
doesn't rub it he's gonna cry with the
position that he has 92 that's an extra
piece and you've got two pawns to
convert this into a full win you trade
the Knight is in time to take it back
this is just over completely 94 Knight
F6 everything under control
yeah everything under control easy win
now for fed to save but uh we've got to
commend him it looked so messy he kept a
calm head and uh Hikaru just started his
best today storm is away and big fish
wow that's a big fish right there man
that's a big big win from Big Fish
better save unbelievable wow and Hikaru
didn't even resign he let his clock run
out he just left a big big result there
oh my goodness look look at this Fabiano
Corona was winning in game one he was
winning here in game three with the
white pieces and for the second time in
a row with a decisive Advantage he has
let it slip it's a fortress black has a
total blockade you can never get rid of
this Black Knight which holds everything
together relax Knight holds the pawns
Rook defense blocks the tracks whoa
James
I'm about I mean I'm just as bad for
probably Sugar's hair like bro what am I
doing like me I'm baffled too I mean
this was your bathroom now or tell me
Tommy has Magnus Carlsen no you planned
I don't know hey
didn't he didn't do that yeah he did he
did yes he did so right now artemiev and
fedosev the new entrance in the top
division in the championship tour here
are the Chelsea Masters they're leading
Hikaru Nakamura and Magus Carlsen who
would have thought this right yeah you
said it Robert it's not going to be a
Carlson against it could it be a feather
save against altemia final it could be
this
what results we're seeing here in this
round all right but this one is this
just a fortress from White has a queen
is there anywhere Fabi can make
something out of this apparently not the
answer is no commentators curse again
draw agreed I had an almost identical
position once against Hikaru and I
managed to hold it you just keep the
Knight and yeah that's the glue
whoa wow I'm gonna catch our breath
what around this has been just some
shocking results amazing incredible
chest there and it looks like the world
champion has to win the fourth Game On
Demand to force into a playoffs let's do
a deep dive with David
David take us through some critical
moments yes so in this position that we
actually left a bit earlier our 10 F was
going porn hunting it was a rook end
game we said it was balanced likely to
fizzle out towards the draw however
Magnus may be miscalculated something
because he simply went down upon he
activated the white Rook a good start
but one point fell he managed to get a
pawn back but suddenly blacks Rook was
the one grabbing all the pawns it's like
Hungry Hippos here grabbing everything
with Tempo and as we saw in the game at
the very end it's simply Four Points
versus three pawns but more importantly
these two black pawns are connected the
game went on a long time but Magnus was
never able to create anything with his
Advantage his majority on the queen side
and if we fast forward to the final
position the black pawn simply stepped
forward the black king supported them
this Pawn is dropping and the black pawn
is promoting whereas White's Pawn is
under lock and key great technique from
artemf he's one of the best end game
players out there and he showed it in
this round
oh
man yeah he's absolutely pissed off I
mean you see him and Magnus uh him and
Hikaru feeling the same way today I mean
they're on the same wavelengths just
absolutely mad at himself right and in
game where he probably could have held
but he was not able to and he's down wow
in the match that's two gas two losses
Robert that's what we've been talking
about from the beginning every player in
this field can take down Magnus or a car
and David gotta give him a shout out he
said that he is the end game Maestro he
knows how to get it done using its
magnets you avoid the end game you're
scared you run away you keep those
Queens on the board but artemium he has
no fear and he's showing that he's here
and he might continue in the winners
bracket sending Magnus down below jeez
Magnus losing two games with white in a
day when's the last time we saw that
happen it's very rare and uh clearly
I'll tell him if he's got his strategy
spot on with the black pieces
water Ron we've had so many twists and
turns on a very angry Magnus Carlson at
the end they're going into round four
these are our results from round three
Magnus Carlsen has to win on demand the
fourth game hikar nagamura has to win on
demand the two big heavy favorites the
two finalists of the Athens Masters in
on the back foot right now on day one of
the chassisable Masters Fabi Liam Fabi
had that golden opportunity but that
match is tied just as Wesley and Levon
aronian is as well there's so much chess
action including a very big open the
Reykjavik open is on right now and the
chessable team visited the tournament to
ask the players about their favorite
opening take a look my name is Johanna
and I'm from Iceland where we are right
now I played a really really good game
yesterday probably one of my best games
in my career he was doing reports high
rated in the knee and always went
playing classical chess I tried to
prepare as much as possible today I
prepared for maybe two hours and I mean
it differs how much time you have so
it's better to do it gradually and
regularly over time so that you're
always on point with your openings
uh however I've had difficulties doing
that because of school work but so I try
to spend as much time as I can while I'm
playing classical tournaments and give
myself at least two three hours of
preparation for each opening for each
opponents and now for our
non-subscribers we've got a twitch break
coming up
foreign
[Music]
just never stops if you are inspired by
all the chats that we've been seeing the
amazing play by the best in the world
this is your chance to take part in the
international Quan championship
hi everybody International Master Danny
wrench here chess.com's Chief chess
officer we are here and excited to be
collaborating and partnering with World
Quant as an official partner of the
champions tour in the year 2023 I'm now
speaking with Chief strategy officer for
World Quant natish mining the people
have met us and now time for the big
questions jumping right into the basics
tell everybody a little more about world
quad and what exactly is it that world
quad does thank you for having me Danny
and you already introduced me I'm the
chief strategy officer at World Quant
World Quant is a global asset management
organization it was founded by Igor
tulsinski in 2007. worldcon today has
over 850 employees who are working
towards designing investment strategies
in multiple asset class across Global
markets
World Quant believes in empowering the
ideas of the talent across the globe and
we have 23 offices in 13 countries today
amazing amazing stuff so tell us now a
little bit more about this project
called World Quant brain so one point is
built on the belief that Talent is
global but opportunity is not and we
strive to take this opportunity to
everyone around the globe world Quant
brain has been designed as a tool which
empowers us to take that opportunity to
anyone that's fantastic seriously that's
amazing I I had no idea about that
learning about this along with our
viewers and obviously as a as a website
in a company with a mission to also
connect Global communities and increase
the opportunity for chess that makes it
even more of a natural partnership tell
me a little bit more from World quads
perspective why you guys run the ITC so
World Quant has this mission of
democratizing quantitative finance and
international Quant Championship is one
of the tools we have to spread the
message about this operator Unity which
World point is offering to everyone to
be a Quant in the world of in the
quantitative space and international
Quant Championship empowers the
individuals to utilize their ideas and
show that they can do it and gives us an
opportunity to take this message to them
wherever they are that's great now you
said the finals will be in person was I
write that it'll be in the Bahamas that
sounds like a pretty great location can
I come yeah absolutely absolutely and I
can okay so I don't know that I'm
qualified to be in the iqc but uh tell
everybody a little more so the finals
are going to be in the Bahamas what will
that be like for those who make it yes
so the finals as you said is planned to
be in Bahamas for the iqc so worldcoin
celebrated its 15th anniversary last
year in 2022 to celebrate that occasion
we are getting the whole world Quant
organization together in Bahamas this
year and we decided that we will
organize the finals of iqc at that event
so this will give an opportunity to our
finalists to meet the world Quant team
in person it will give them an
opportunity to watch the culture and
rigor of the organization and we are
very excited that everybody will be able
to get together at that event in Bahamas
well this has been awesome nitish thank
you so much this is where I remind
everybody it's their chance to get
involved in the iqc the international
quad Championship you can use the
command iqc you can visit the world
Quant brain website we encourage you to
do so ASAP registration is open until
May so it's time to jump in and maybe
you'll get to meet the CSO and others in
the Bahamas maybe I'll be there I don't
if I'm lucky I don't know but it sounds
like a great time either way and the
Tish uh the Chess World and the
Champions chess tour thanks World Quant
for their partnership and we're looking
forward to the rest of the year together
thank you Denny and good luck to the
community for participating in iqc
imagine an ultimate quad challenge where
your unique way of thinking could Propel
you further while competing against some
of the best
the international Quan Championship 2023
a three-stage competition where teams of
one to four people will use World quad's
brain simulation platform to build
algorithms
Ready Set Quant
itors gain points based on the quality
and the quantity of their ideas those
who perform well may be considered for
internship or full-time employment
opportunities at World Quant winners
could receive cash prizes and attend the
live Global finals in the Bahamas
don't wait break into the world of
quantitative Finance in one of the
largest Quant competitions on the planet
sign up
team up
train
compete
[Applause]
are you the net Quant champion
wow what a day of drama and auction it's
been in adjustable Masters big big
results big turnarounds but earlier
today there was another big result for
women chats we do have the winner of the
women's candidate a huge congratulations
to Lei Ting Jae who will be challenging
to wenjen in July for the world
championship match that is a big one
it's going to be a big fight Robert but
latency what a comeback this was by her
yeah late tenji slightly higher rated
between the two players but tanjonggi
had a good head-to-head record coming
into the match and she struck first in
game one but later she showed that she
is all class she won game two solid Drew
game three and then one two in a row she
sealed the deal with a game despair that
is some great stuff wow amazing chess
amazing fight there well some of the
players have to show amazing fight here
at the chessable Masters and also make
their comebacks because as we know
Magnus Carlsen is currently trailing
vladislav time you have going in to this
final round round four is about to start
David how do you see this one being
played out what do you think is going on
in magnus's mind right now is chaos in
his mind who knows at this point for
Magnus he's done it before he won his
previous game with the black pieces but
to compose himself I'll tell me it's now
going to be playing Ultra solid it's not
going to be easy I think Magnus is up
against it in this one I think he needs
a bit of magic a bit of luck maybe to
even bring it to Armageddon yeah if
Magnus Carlsen wins we will have the
bidding Armageddon and what about Hikaru
Nakamura he is second on the tour
standings the finalist of the air things
Masters the winner of the American Cup
on the back foot against federative I
can't say I'm surprised that you know it
wasn't the expected result overall but
it's not surprising to me Federal staff
is that good as is artemia and artemia
may be the worst person to face in the
world when you need a victory and he is
the white pieces he does not take risks
he plays a very solid style the one
piece of good news for Magnus Carlsen
his all three games have been won by the
black pieces in this match and guess
what he gets black yeah yeah and he
starts with Knight F3 James that's a
solid start when you need a draw to win
the match of course you need to go
King's Indian here big fella something
very strange and for some change okay
you're gonna have to make it happen here
or you're going I mean you're going
You're Gonna not eliminate but you get
to the losers bracket here it's gonna be
tough to see Magnus in the limit in the
the uh the lose breakfast so it's pretty
tough It's Horus right G6 we got Bishop
G2 Bishop G7 come on let's see a D4 D6
D6 D6 Magnus D6 he's willing him damn
it might happen there it is there it is
it's a dub it's a dub it's a win okay
good we're good yeah he could not play
symmetrical chess he could no longer
just copy his opponent's moves that
would have just fizzled out towards uh
boring equality really sterile positions
now it's really flexible all the pieces
on the board James you're happy with
this one absolutely king zinny of course
actually I be my first GMO TV with
King's Indian so I was happy I'm like
getting ready all day baby forever right
now you love the kid stuff nice C3 this
is a strange variation of course they
usually go with like A4 here too as well
so this is a strange one but you can get
lots of play kid is is you know when you
need it when you go for kid and that's
definitely something that we're going to
see from Magnus here in the World Champ
hopefully he's able to strike yeah but
the problem is you just can't afford a
draw so at this point maggots isn't
really even playing chess he's playing
for a specific result so if there's the
best move which is going to trade queens
and keep it quality he can't go for that
and that's not a fun position to be in
especially against artemia who will
punish you and will take no risk of Zone
absolutely yeah tell me if we're trying
to bully Magnus with the thought of
equality with a thought of a draw with a
thought of an end game even and uh it's
rare to say that but yeah tell me if you
can definitely use the odds which are
stacked in his favor now to uh push
Magnus in certain directions and this
last move already forcing Magnus to
think that white a pawn is going to push
itself even further up the board if
given the opportunity well it can also
occupy the center anytime he wants there
we go uh the pawn really clamping down
on that black queen side and Magnus okay
he looked away he doesn't look too
unhappy but a bit of an odd one gonna
say this last queen movie what is that
David Queen D3 uh don't ask me Robert
hey that was a good rhyme there but I
don't want to be the one to answer the
question it doesn't really make so much
sense but I think he's just waiting for
Magnus to strike in the center and when
he does with E5 or C5 some kind of Pawn
break he'll slide his Rook to D1 so I
just think that Artemis does not want to
commit his pawns forward because as soon
as you push your pawns forward you may
create some weak squares that you can't
deal with so well so I think artemium
he's just keeping everything tamed for
the time being but he kind of has to do
something at some point yeah I think
he's waiting as you say Robert from
Magnus to push report and then he's just
gonna trade off open up a line and try
and swap off the queen swap up all the
pieces and uh kill all of magnus's fun
so right now it's a bit of a standoff
Magnus wants to push a pawn of course
he's really cramped the black pieces
stuck in their own first three ranks but
he can't afford to do that he needs to
win he needs to keep pieces and
difficult Tanya yeah and it's telling
how for the first time in the match our
Tamia is also ahead on the clock out of
the opening because my Dr Carlson with
the black pieces needs to find a way to
keep the game going to somehow create
his stances against the player who is so
difficult to beat when he just needs a
draw our time we have just needs to keep
it solid to put Magnus in the loser's
bracket something that Magnus is not
used to in the Champions Chester uh
while this heats up while Magnus has a
think on how he can create some Chaos on
the board let's do a little opening tour
and take a look on some of the other
matches as Hikaru is also trailing
David let's take a look at that one
Hikaru phariseev another big matchup
Hikaru on the back foot has to score a
win to level the match I think few would
have predicted that Robert at the start
yeah no for at the start everyone's like
Hikaru Nakamura that's my streamer
that's my guy but what happens when you
play ferrosev and you're a car you say
well that's the guy who beat me the last
time we faced off in title Tuesday five
times in a row and so Federal save is
not going to back down and we look at
this current position this is the type
of position that a car wants it's messy
we don't just have a symmetrical
position but that said he needs to find
a way to win he needs some inroads for
an attack and Pedro saves King is
perfectly safe castled over there the D6
Pawn with that Rook staring down that's
a permanent weakness and I just like the
look of this position for white even
though I think this gives hikar a good
chance to play for a win getting that
done is another question yeah both these
big hitters David though playing with
the black pieces have to win on demand
but I agree with Robert there that if
anyone's got the kind of chances you
need to win it is this position
for sure I think for the match situation
for this game specifically it's been a
success for Hikaru I'm not saying his
position is good I think I would choose
white as Robert mentioned there but it
is imbalanced that is the key you just
need that one word imbalance the
position give your opponent new
questions and I will also mention FedEx
he's not the type of player who can go
for a draw he's not Mr solid he doesn't
have that kind of reverse gear the kind
of pull the brakes type of Chess uh that
some of the other top players have
that's maybe why he's never really hit
the elite levels in classical chess uh
that slight lack of consistency I've
also played a tournament once in St
Louis I was half a point behind him uh
heading into the final game he only
needed a draw to win the tournament with
white and he lost very very quickly
against Sam Shanklin there and uh I do
fear for him here suddenly the black
piece is getting active look at the
evaluation bar slightly in Black's favor
the last couple moves didn't really make
sense for federal sale the queen sliding
back to D2 what's your night on B1 doing
it's stuck at home and he goes for this
Pawn so he's going for Pure liquidation
thinking this gives isn't the best
chance to hold but look at Hikaru go
that is tremendous understanding James
like he's like get those Queens on the
board see what happens look at that
night on F4 by the way right that night
is nastiest a nasty night on F4
especially if you take on F3 too as well
the Knight is just they are stuck right
there you even have a chances of attack
we love attacking obviously Rook G8 G5
G4 after you take on F3 just to open the
G file but again the Knight is very bad
on B1 we have an active Rook now on C uh
C8 we even have chances to even play
something like Knight to D4 and try to
highlight the fact that your Bishop is
really bad on C2 as well there's so many
things here that can go wrong with
White's uh position yeah so maybe we
examine what happens if he just takes
the Queens off the board for example the
black king takes I think the main
dilemma here for fedisev is as you guys
mentioned how to bring this Knight into
the game the problem in this exact
position is that if you move the Knight
then after a Trader pawns at the very
least black can drop a knight in with a
check hitting the king and of course
gobbling up the pawn on C3 restoring the
material balance yes it's level material
yes it's symmetrical blacks pieces are
far more active than white suddenly this
white Rook is hit has to move suddenly
the black Rook from the other side comes
in this Rook is a monster this Knight is
a monster this bishop can trade off any
time he wants and this Knight is also
going to jump in it's one-way traffic
all about Black and Hikaru I think he's
really caught fed himself off guard I
think this has been a dream for him
right huge Advantage uh eval bar here
right after A5 what is the move what is
what do we do here it's this huge
Advantage from for black engine wise I
would be too tempted to capture this
Knight I do want to take it it's forces
the Queen's off too uh if you take with
the pawn suddenly a checkmating attack
will happen queen of night a dream
attacking combo and this is actually on
the board as well so the Queens are off
and now how does black take advantage
James I think you called it earlier what
about this night jump it's time to put a
score boom there it is I hear you I hear
you Hikaru that's my guy all right 94
for the score it's a big boy move you
got to take that after captures there's
Rook C2 and the Rooks on the seventh
rank or a second Rank and then two is
hanging and Knight hasn't developed
Knight H3 is coming on tap I mean get
the man off the board the other Rook is
coming to see it it's all the pieces
against Whites Whites King this is
looking very dangerous for Fantasy right
out of the opening with such few pieces
left
yeah the dream game how many moves was
this we're early on right now
20 right now but uh yeah it could be
over in the next five ten moves it just
looks beautiful the same game it was
self-induced though right federal state
brought his Queen backwards right the
queen was active he said let's go back
and he blocked in his own pieces so
Federal Sav he's played so well in the
first three games he was worse for maybe
a handful of moves not many he had the
better position often in those first
three but here in game fours he's
collapsed completely and the good news
for him is he's starting up a point so
even if he loses he'll get uh Armageddon
with bidding but this is not the way you
want to go in our Armory and if hikar is
indeed able to win the game I think
someone needs to do a count has white
won any games today it seems to be black
Wesley so levonoronian traded blows with
black magnus's match blacks won every
single game for the same beat
with black Knack is about to win with
black here it's just black he's okay you
can blame Fabiano because he had two
winning positions with white and lamlay
was able to draw both those games but
yeah you're right the black the black
piece is second move not a disadvantage
here in today's Tesla Masters division
one and right now for hikara Nakamura
he's well on his way to winning this
game and sending us to Armageddon I just
it feels weird like this wasn't the
federal almost like Federal save isn't
playing like someone else took his chair
for this game just because he played at
such a high level in the first three and
this was a collapse
yeah what do you even do here what do
you even do resign okay okay I think
it's Crossing his mind right now he's
thinking about it but the thing is that
it doesn't get him anyway he wants to
try of course to keep the game going uh
you try to live another move and hope
for the best but Knight D4 it's hard to
even come up with a move forward you
take on D4 Rook Cedar looks game over
you move that Bishop light jumping on to
E2 the F3 Pawn hanging
yeah it just looks like a car was
bounced straight back out of the opening
what a beast you have eight points stuck
on the back rank the knight in The Rook
especially after Rook takes C2 you can't
really move them now you can move the D2
I guess if you like actually maybe you
can go Knight D2 and everything you just
hang B2 and then the Rook maybe even
bring the other Rook at me B2 is on tap
at some point
oh geez 92 Jack I wouldn't pick what you
want do you know what I mean yeah just
take and create a possible and put it on
D3 you're never getting rid of that one
never getting past that pawn
tough game it's horrible disposition
poor fed a say of he's done so well but
against these beasts you can't relax for
one minute no I think the best choice
here is Bishop A4 you do not want to
allow that Rook to get active for black
so even though you give the F3 Pawn with
check and your king may have to get into
the corner of the board you still have
some chances here because you are
threatening to take on before at long
last get your knight off the first Rank
and you are just a couple moves away
from developing your pieces that said
your king is in a mating net over there
he played Bishop is out of desperation
not desire but it does give him a chance
to kind of coordinate his pieces at long
last nicely called by you Robert and I'm
just wondering what happens if a CaRu
gets the other Rook into the game Rook
d8 comes to mind you want to try and
trade off why it's the only active piece
on D1 it also makes sure that white
doesn't complete development this is why
you always finish your development yeah
I wish uh we wish you told Vladimir that
earlier look at this night look at this
Rook ugh ugly for white but he's still
alive and the game still goes on so okay
he found the best defense he's composed
himself can he cling on it's uh very
much kind of tightrope stuff right now
just one slip you've fallen off and
you're gone but uh Hikaru needs to
finish things he suddenly hasn't looked
at his best Tanya your move is on the
board great call there great shout and
okay
on B1 it still needs a move you can't
take it before you probably have to take
on B4 to get that night out otherwise
it's got no future you're basically
playing without the knight in the rook
and I love that move and Robert I say
that because this makes sure that white
doesn't get that B4 Pawn you've got Rook
C1 coming in with the Checkmate 90 maybe
more players who've taken back with the
Rook we're going to the open file but
what Hikaru Nakamura just did he says no
development for you and he's happy to
move his Knight back because he's
attacking the pawn E4 and remember
Black's not down material anymore you
sacrificed a Pawn on D6 you've got it
back on F3 and now your Knights are
active and they're about to pick off the
pawns this is great play for my car
Nakamura still white cannot complete the
development and this is just terrible
news yep what'd you do about this guy
you can't move your knight out suddenly
you lose this Pawn you can't take the
other one as you mentioned there Robert
look how paralyzed white is here just a
Total Domination you'll get this off the
screen David sorry this is uh this is
brutal pin this way pin this way white
resigns yep it's uh still looking great
to follow actually in that position
in the next move all black needs
actually is to get his Rook to the back
rack this white king is mated uh this
white king nowhere to run and um yeah
just Flawless player we were just the
first three games right you're like man
what if it's just what a game here
absolutely domination yeah you don't
keep these top players down for long you
really have to hit them while they're uh
kind of finding their footing but okay
he's got his Rook active feather save I
like demo yeah night's going to start
gobbling up horns and creating threats
on the way it's coming 94 Knight of two
yeah yeah again you don't even have time
to capture him before after 94 when he
goes the other way oh my God he goes
Knight to H3 and you know what that does
James that takes away the G1 Square from
the King what a guy what come on man
unbelievable
and that Rook May lift up from C6 to G6
oh my God that's actually pretty hard to
stop so I I won't be surprised if that
kind of meeting that occurs here it's
that straightforward white piece is not
in position to stop that Checkmate and
at first I have to say Federal say I've
made this backward queen move that was
bad but since then Hikaru has played
perfect chess he's making it look easy
it was not that simple he's played
precisely and this is precisely how the
game is going to end I believe that Rook
is sliding up and delivering a Checkmate
what an idea I mean can we just admire
the last two moves by Hikaru recapturing
with the King to do it and he does that
so instantly okay uh David just this
moment Ruby it's such a natural move but
he makes sure that white knight can't
develop so this goes king da then he
Retreats with the Knight to G5 and
you're like he's gonna pick up that E4
Pawn makes a lot of sense right but
instead of picking up
34.9283 really boxing up that King in a
Kill Zone White's gotta go Knight D2 try
to get that Knight to F3 to defend that
G1 Square it might be as simple as
Robert saying just Checkmate in three
yeah one two three bang right you also
have Knight F2 on top and you're winning
a piece full Knight takes F2 give me the
bishop you can hit the button that's the
resign button I mean and that's game
over I think uh he'll resign any moment
now if I had to say simply nothing to be
done you either lose a piece or you get
mated wow that means that would be an
Armageddon it's still it's still not
over I know it and I know that's the
thing is commentators curse but I don't
think it will be in this one this just
looks absolutely busted it looks like
it's hopeless yeah it would have to be a
mouse slip and that's gonna hurt but it
would have to be a mouth flip for this
one to go down for a regard how many
times has your car a mouse lift I never
see it
very good on the mouse so good on this
thing and you do because otherwise
you're probably just getting checkmated
but now you're losing at minimum of
Bishop the Knight takes the pawn it hits
the king with check and the bishop I
think we're about to see that and hikara
wins this game
oh wow man we got kids watching you
can't do this bro this is uh yeah
sadistic wow it is but he can still win
that Bishop right he can still go for it
if he wants it because the White Knight
will stop the checkmated
yeah I don't need it yet I'm gonna get
it later he's gonna get it on the next
move because it was really the only way
for feathers you have to not get
checkmated is to give up a piece but
that just means resigns that essentially
is resigning yeah and talking of
resigning Tanya you called it it's tutu
we're heading to Armageddon for the same
house designed
oh my God that means we're gonna have
bids on this one yeah but let me ask you
something it looks like the result is in
the book and a car has officially won I
was about to ask if you were photos
saved would you have spent some time
before it's not just to compose yourself
giving you a little bit more of a break
I guess it's not going to start until
these games are done anyway but I just
feel like you know for federal sale he
needs to get that out of his head
somehow throw that game out the window
and never look at it again yeah
that's a very good point actually that's
really good strategy because so much
went wrong with white and you just calm
your nerves a little bit put it behind
you get ready for a new format get into
that mindset it probably would have made
a little sense to just burn that clock
and calm yourself down but right now it
is Magnus who perhaps needs to calm down
because his heart's going to be racing
very fast with what's going on on the
board white looks dominating here you've
got the bishop pad the control on the D
file the only two open files on the
board are controlled by our time you
have right now I'm not gonna lie that's
probably the worst King City I've ever
seen in my life bro and I mean Magnus
not a real Kings Indian player like he
don't actually really play it like that
he can't even play anything but he
doesn't play like he's playing the
king's Indian positionally and that's
just not what you're supposed to do with
King's Indian but and it is not looking
good does it means look at this Knight
oh man this is rough this is a rough
King's India yeah what a move what an
instructive move there from vladislav
I'll tell me if even in a situation
where he's happy with the draw he's
definitely going for the most principled
options this last move it looks like
you're slightly loosening the white king
weakening uh the shelter around it but
the most important point is to dominate
that black knight that Black Knight on
H6 is going to take an age to get back
in the game in the meantime vladislav
will have asserted domination will have
got over all of his pieces to dream
squares Magnus desperately trying to ask
questions try to uh open up lines for
his pieces but there must be a way here
it feels like white has so much space
there must be a way to shut things down
uh blocking Black's pieces even further
this last move was good though six right
break it open needs it to be done you go
F5 takes uh takes on H6 I mean you could
go at five and then take only six take
on that five play six it's something
like that you know me but but the thing
population over everything that's what
Magnus wants even if it's a good move
that's true Magnus wants the position to
open up because he's saying I'm not in a
situation where let's say we just do
simple trades that's not good for
magnets but as soon as you start going
forward that's when Magnus the chance to
strike back because let's say even Pawn
takes a five the G file is open that's
where the white king is I feel like
Magnus would be thrilled to get in this
position even if the bar set white is
better Max I'll take this I need winning
chances even if it means I lose the game
all right yeah so something like this
it's very complicated it looks quite
good for white to me at least visually
uh just because this black Bishop will
get locked in but some lines open
towards the white king as Robert
mentions and uh what else how does
vladislav shut things down is there a
safety first approach I don't see it yet
uh feels like maybe this one is the
safest just trading off a set of Pawns
but after black recaptures black will
bring his pieces back to life now the
Black Knight has a route back towards
the center the black porn will step
forward opening up this king's Indian
Bishop again on the long diagonal okay
he's gone for the safe approach no
complications no mess there he's still
out of time on the clock oh now oh yeah
exactly goodness yeah James you said it
before I could he's gone for uh this
skewer here the queen of rook in the
same line but I still believe this is
what Magnus wants he may lose some
material the evil bar saying that
artemia was better and he is objectively
right but practically speaking this does
give Magnus more chance to win as I said
before even it means he might lose the
game yeah total mess I guess now you do
have options you could consider for
example taking this Pawn even if you
move your queen out the way I'm not sure
where then yes white can win material
but the white king actor uh is slightly
vulnerable long term sorry
um so yeah still a mess but feather
serve and I'll tell me if uh kind of
experiencing different fortunes here
I'll tell me of
um yeah he's done everything right he's
done everything that FedEx didn't do
he's kept control when necessary and
okay Point explore I'm expecting that to
be I was gonna say recaptured maybe you
could move the White Queen as well I
don't know if you want to get carried
away capture the black queen right now
it's got to be calculated calculation
over everything as Jim says and that's
the most forcing move I guess it's uh
the most linear variation
that you can try and work out but it is
still complicated I've got to say under
five minutes is I'll tell me I'm gonna
get nervous that's the big question
four seconds to beat Magnus like you
know how many people got four seconds
you're gonna just flag against Magnus
right or like you just mess up you hang
a rook you do something crazy Magnus
effect but it doesn't affect artemiev at
all but I just don't like the trajectory
of where this clock right now because
I'm looking at this position I'm like
you know Magnus he's getting more
chances against the white king now Tim
if he continues to use that clock this
is messy the position we had a few
seconds of the clock it was an end game
the moves were a bit simpler here this
remains complicated and that's when
mistakes happen
wow okay he's moved his Queen I'll tell
me if he did get her out the way of that
attack the black queen was threatened as
well she did scoot out the way as well
but suddenly you can go and grab the
black Rook but it does come at the cost
of your beautiful dark Square Bishop
with white I do fear on the dark squares
that long-term Magnus will get some
counter play we'll have some tricks the
black dot Square Bishop doesn't look
great right now but imagine it coming to
life imagine the black dark Square
Bishop parked on the Square like E5 in
the center Magnus will surely try and
keep the Queens on if possible there are
some tricks there that he has to
navigate
can you keep the Queens on it might take
on H3 first though I mean can you take
on H3 try to open the G file with a
smile like whoo we you know this it
could be possible take on H3 and then
take on G2 we're about to see oh I think
there's a big problem with it though
what is it the bishop on B8 still lives
Rook A7 wow right that Bishop actually
plays a part in the game I'm gonna
capture it next move but if you capture
it you get checkmate along the seventh
rank so I was looking at that too I was
like what can I take I throw in GTX H3
an intermediate move the answer is not
in this position yes gross A7 you gotta
be looking at that that's crazy you have
to take this bishop there's no other
choice Rook takes B8 I don't want to
really I really don't want to trade I
think the problem he's realized as well
that he wants to keep the Queens on Rook
takes B8 but suddenly there's another
trick Bishop takes C6 to flexing away
this black queen if Queen takes Bishop
suddenly The Rook Falls no longer
protected and even if you try and run
away even after Bishop takes born if you
try and move your queen there will be
tricks for example later on of just
trading off getting rid of this rook and
uh now after Rook A8 you get the black
queen off the board no more losing
chances I don't know if you're still
winning but you definitely weren't
losing it I'll tell me if we'll take the
match in that case so Magnus now he's
caught between a rock and a hard place
he has to make a decision but maybe the
best decision is getting the Queens off
objectively but that won't get him the
win I mean with Knight F5 we just try
and move now at this point
any nothing works you have to think we
takes B8 is the only move which may send
him uh to the losers bracket F5 the
queen moves hitting this loose bishop
and white will remain a whole Rook up no
matter what tough times for Magnus I
think he's gonna lose he's going to drop
down to the losers bracket
yeah he's looking away look at him on
the camera he's disgusted with this
position
Magnus Carlsen did try to create his
chances with that move F6 but very
nicely navigated the complications uh by
our time you have there and Magnus takes
the right decision in this one to trade
the Queens keeps the bar where it is but
it looks like our time you have the one
with the advantage there is no attack
now he has the extra exchange there are
weaknesses on the queen side if anyone's
winning this it's got to be white
I don't know what else to add it looks
pretty safe right now if the queens were
still on the board the reason Magnus
could have been optimistic was because
the white king is really really open but
without the Queens there's no way to
ever attack it and at the right moment
on tap is that Rook exchange the white
Rook can land on A8 trade off the black
Rook no danger and Artemis of silence me
because I was saying oh this position it
looks adventurous or chances of Magnus
Carlson the king is open and our team
says uh not when I'm playing chess I'm
gonna be very precise here Force the
Queens off Force the Rooks off next and
what was that about winning chances you
got zero and it's just a great play from
our temu because from a distance even
Magnus believed in his chances he
thought that he could maybe keep the
Queens on the board but the answer was
he could not and with that his winning
chances are gone it looks like our 10
minute is going to sail through to the
winter semifinals yeah the only thing
that could stop him now are Nerfs or
Mouse slips and uh I don't think he's
shown either of those uh in the uh
action we've seen so far he doesn't even
want to trade off Rooks he's Mr
ambitious right now he hits that black
Bishop which faster move and only then
will he decide what to do next still
full control for white
what an absolute Beast are Timmy have
came in same facial expression
throughout the whole thing you don't see
any emotion from him at all he just came
I have a job to do right I have a job to
do and that's the calculate and play
this game in the win and try to win this
match and so far he's doing that yup it
does look like he's close now but they
do say you sometimes slip up when you're
close to that result when you can see
the Finishing Line right what can Magnus
try if magnus's dark Square Bishop does
get back into the game maybe but there
we go Rooks are off the board oh wow and
Magnus just has to don't take the B6
spawn that's the only trick in the
position Bishop C5 check would be an
absolute disaster he takes the other
Pawn Yeah he takes the other pawn and
whoops sorry I was just looking at the
other game there but uh if we go back to
magnus's game uh we do see yeah there's
no danger again just to show Tanya's
trick don't take it now either because
there is a nasty fork in the position a
double attack hitting the king hitting
the rook and Magnus would suddenly get
to Armageddon but that's never going to
happen the white Rook has plenty of safe
squares for example F4 and luckily the
white king is very safe in the corner
because the white Bishop protects the
long diagonal no checks no hope white
should be safe
if I'm artemia at some moment I might
even consider in that position giving up
the Rook for the light score Bishop
opposite colored Bishops if I can steal
that pass Pawn that's the one thing
giving Magnus a chance here that pawn on
H3 it's very far Advanced and so it's
going to be hard to stop completely but
if you can give up some material to win
it I think our tournament will do that
to make sure his losing chances are at
zero
yep almost zero right now but he would
love to just uh remove that final bit of
doubt and okay could the clock be a
factor here under two minutes we've said
before he's pretty cool Under Pressure
there but uh wow giving up the Rook for
the bishop here I mean all he needs is a
drop
bro I'm not I'm not losing this one says
artemiev and you know zeros make it a
draw this is it I clinched the match yes
he's playing the Mad situation and not
the position right now
yeah he's uh wow what a classy move if
the Black Knight does try to get into
the game it will just be chopped off uh
in the near future yep he's just got
full control as long as you don't allow
that black knight in I'm not even sure
where but uh in to create some nuisance
then you will be holding this one it
should be a draw
the White Knight will be jumping on to
D5 next attacking the B6 spawn in fact
even in this position despite being a
pawn down it is the queen side pawns
that can be dangerous all right time you
have what a Flawless way to to finish
the match
just great practical choices here giving
up that rook in the end sacrificing it
back keeping everything under control
and there we have it 95 B5 has been
pushed a Magnus just delaying the
inevitable here it looks like Magnus
Carlton will be in the losers bracket
tomorrow yeah because the next two moves
for white can be putting the king in
front of the pawn you want to blockade
the past pawn and then bring your knight
which just left forward back towards
that pawn and trying to capture it so
I'm with you Tanya it looks like
magnus's chances they are very slim
almost none at this point and it's been
a great match from our team winning two
games with the black pieces and then
here in the fourth and critical final
game he says you are not gonna have a
winning position you are not going to
get those chances I'm going to remain
solid trade off the pieces give up my
Rook back for that bishop and now really
there should not be winning chances for
Magnus yeah no way to hustle anymore uh
he killed all the hopes and dreams
killed all the fun from the position
it's cynical chest but that's what you
need to do at the top level to succeed
that's what fed to save should have done
with the white pieces just locked it
down kept things solid but he went down
in flames instead against Nakamura so
yeah right now I'm expecting exactly
Robert's plan under 30 seconds though
you need to move like oh hey man hey
you're playing with fire here you gotta
make a move yeah at least he's trying to
eliminate that remaining black Pawn on
the queen side he's going to play C4
next trade off one set of Pawns get
closer to that draw Still logical but he
should have played it a bit quicker
maybe maybe 30 seconds run for doubt
how confident would we be here in the
studio 100 now of the draw with white if
I were playing the game uh well if I'm
playing I'm bound to mess up somewhere
but I do think that the chances are
extremely high because the only way you
lose is if somehow that pawn gets to H2
which takes a journey you're gonna need
to move your Bishop back put your knight
in push the pawn and even then it's hard
to see it continuing up the board so I
do think that our team has everything
under control the one thing that he
would need to be careful about is if the
knights get traded off the board and
black is able to freeze the White Queen
side pawns there could be an end game
there with the black king runs on over
to the queen side so it's far away but
the point is that if these Knights and I
appreciate you David getting those
Knights off the board and then black
gets to throw in this before move then
the king runs over and we see that
actually would be a winning end game
suddenly the white pawns are right for
the picking the black Bishop's just
going to come and take them and win the
game so yeah this is unlikely to happen
but that was does show the urgency that
vladislav needs to show he does drop his
Knight back hitting this bishop and the
problem for Magnus is when the bishop
moves the king comes and uh yeah this
Pawn is not long for the world you could
try and give a check try to create some
Fork some nuisance but the white king
will step forward I don't think you can
ever promote this Pawn because the white
Bishop's Eye line is fixed on the H1
Square the promotion square but at least
Magnus is trying some tricks at least
he's setting some traps and with 25
seconds vladislav needs to dodge them
and uh yeah Magnus he's doing the right
thing he's sitting there composing
himself saying okay one last trick one
last uh hope for this game
not gonna work
yeah but it's it's it always feels like
it's not over till it's over against
Magnus and vladislav artemian's clock
situation is again very scary to look at
we're just 25 seconds he needs to watch
out for these ideas of the queen queen
side pawns getting fixed on B3 C2 but
this is a big moment uh in the
chassisable Masters as Magnus Carlton
does stare at his first uh first showing
in the loser's bracket if he is not able
to win this one and it looks like that
move C4 it's so important because all
these ideas are fixing that pawn on C2
and creating a past one on the queen
side with that C4 Pawn now that's gone
as well four seconds no hope lives
except the clock six now and the V for
Pawn Falls is this over
oh the Black Knight is coming in it
should be a draw of course white could
even just give up a piece as long as you
remove all of Black's pawns from the
board but
um yeah I'm really worried about the
clock situation actually nerves I mean
they have to be kicking in at some point
and uh now the Black Flag can come in
with the track
oh flag is love playing with fire
magnets pulls this one off
I mean that will be that'll be nothing
short of a miracle
but we've seen him do that he needs to
buy a lottery ticket wow
okay he's gonna throw in a night check
though you can do it on the clock okay
don't take that H3 Pawn all the Discover
checks with the Knight landing on F2 oh
what that second H Pawn that could be
dangerous like H5 H4 check and oh my God
oh my goodness what happened H2 he's
coming he's just Bishop he goes back
five and he takes The
Bishop's face
oh my God
just last he needed to buy a lottery
ticket he needed to buy that lottery
ticket David he resigned you got to be
kidding me oh no what just happened she
wouldn't have to be kidding me bro well
now we see Magnus Carson he can't
believe what just happened well no one
can this was all but over and now Magnus
lives another day we've seen him do this
over and over again and our time we have
now not only does he need to deal with
this loss he needs to shift his mindset
his momentum everything his Armageddon
coming up and I have to say that's
Magnus Advantage now look at his hair
that just happened not right now that
way it was all up and for you know
immediately after that happened his hair
got all messed up I mean that's that's
crazy with David he looks less shocked
than Magnus I've got to say Magnus more
shocked than anyone he's uh yeah women
will raise we'll have to unpack that one
later but this one meanwhile Wesley so
gonna take the win wow it's all about
the black pieces in this day uh in the
chessable Masters so far black simply
has a rook for Bishop once the black
combined to attack some of the white
pawns especially on the king side
left One's Gonna resign yeah we haven't
seen a single win with the white pieces
in here levana running he's down a rook
for a bishop for now that pawn on A6
remains on the board but you see that F2
Pawn on a dark Square that's a light
Square Bishop from White which means
that black is going to team up on it and
you're not going to be able to defend it
so it looks like Wesley so the third
place finisher from the air things
Master he's looking like he's gonna make
it through to the semi-finals of the
winners bracket here at the chessel
Masters but it wasn't easy he lost early
on the first game and then he was able
to strike back but David James is this
as over as the evil bar suggests no I'm
not even going nope because the last
game we just saw I can't even believe
I'm still trying to wrap my head around
what just happened in that Magnus game
that was the true Magnus effect I mean
this one seems over but I mean who knows
at this point what's going to happen in
these games yeah who knows but okay now
the white pawns have been forced to step
forward there will be some nasty checks
from behind the black Rook can go Pawn
hunting I think levon's banking
everything on some counter play the
white Rook wants to go up to the seventh
Rank and start taking that lone black a
pawn but it should simply be too slow
um I'm stunned to trust the eval bar
here live on Iranian as well five
seconds on the clock to defend this
miserable position that's a check
working has to start running oh yeah the
pawns are dropping yeah oh my God yeah
this one should be the end now you can
go hunting that's the only one that's
the only hope that he has he will pick
up the A7 pawn and then maybe try and
put some tricks E6 hanging while The
Bishop's been pinned now is there some
hope no you can lose all your Pawns in
the process and the black Rook is behind
what might be a past Pawn so I like what
LeBron's doing he's giving some chances
but after this check here unfortunately
the rook's hitting you from all
directions
yeah both the Rooks hitting you and uh
there we go
for you yikes and then take on A6 just
give me every pawn and wow Rick F6 first
GG yeah now just check away kick away
that white king and uh Wesley can
breathe he can relax lavonda shaking his
head you can't believe it and he's the
one who won the first game and then
Wesley's just stolen this match from him
yeah what a day it's been just so many
twists and tons normally tournaments
they start everyone's a bit nervous a
bit cagey we see a few quick draws here
and there but this one's just been fire
all day uh all the decisive results yeah
but the Shockers gotta be the Magnus
comeback I mean what happened though it
was two moves and everything over and
now we've got an Armageddon on our hands
it's a problem when you're glutton for
time trouble you end up getting in
severe time pressure and it costs you
and right now I mean this game here it
looks like Levon it's gonna cost him but
he couldn't keep it up the momentum
after game one was fully in his favor he
then after winning with black he
struggled with white he lost the second
game with white he lost the match here
Wesley so has confirmed his spot in the
winter semifinal I think he's the first
player to do so yeah
and the only one to not take it to the
Armageddon wow that is an amazing
performance after losing game one Wesley
takes down Lavon aronian with a big
match win goes into the semi-finals
while Magnus Carlsen Hikaru Nakamura
will play will fight it out and Fabiano
caruana will be taken to the armageddens
yeah and Lemley at ferosev artemiev I
mean for them they were the three new
entrants into the field but they went
toe-to-toe thus far and they're not done
I expect at least one of them to make
their way through I know they may be the
underdog on paper but in Armageddon
bidding you never know everyone has
their chances it's crazy the two world
champions Magnus and Hikaru here were
down in the match we thought it was all
over and then they said this is why I'm
a world champion I swung back and out of
here and now it's the level match we're
going to Armageddon we don't know what's
going to happen now and momentum is
definitely on our side yeah and it
happens so fast I think we need an
action replay on how Magnus worked his
magic how he managed to trick vladislav
artemiev it was actually in this
position where I'll tell me have started
to go wrong started to lose the threat
of the game he only had a few seconds
left if he had a bit more time he would
have realized that Black's Knight coming
into the position was magnus's only
trick he could have for example dropped
his Bishop back ready to eliminate the
Black Knight if it ever lands on this
square and now next white just brings
his King forward and takes this Pawn
easy draw nothing to work uh work on
there but instead he dropped his Knight
back allowing Magnus to get active this
nasty check now there's a trap suddenly
a discover check here from the bishop
would be deadly and the trick started
working in magnus's favor we saw the
black king step forward hinting maybe at
another Pawn being thrown down the board
but this was the killer uh blow the
final blunder from our temmiev no time
on his clock he got greedy he took a
pawn but he forgot that after this black
porn steps forward the only way to
prevent it promoting is to drop your
Bishop back and suddenly a skewer black
brings his Bishop forward hitting this
bishop trying to deflect it away and the
only way to stop this black pawn is to
move it back and your night falls Magnus
won with this trick he won the piece won
the game and Armageddon time
one really has to admire Magnus
Carlson's ability to create chances and
to create opportunities in a position
where it does seem impossible well one
can say that against Magnus you have to
beat him Thrice once in the opening once
in the middle game once in the end game
if you can't you will lose and that's
what happened we have one missed
opportunity and with that Magnus Carlsen
Strikes Back these are our results well
there's been so much in action and drama
in these four games but we're just
getting started because there's more
drama coming up with three matches going
into bidding armaged and take a look at
that Wesley so is the only player to
take it to the semi-finals in the rapid
Portion by defeating Levon aronian who
finds himself in the losers bracket in
the elimination bracket for tomorrow and
Iranian did get the first win but Wesley
winning in game two and game four with
the black pieces just took it away with
two and a half points we're gonna have
three three big armor Gardens but before
that we do have our semi-finalists
joining us Wesley so let's bring him on
Wesley congratulations
hi guys yeah thanks for having me yes
what's up it was a pretty tough match
losing the first game with white was
um really a big blow to me but I managed
to come back because the one was making
some uh unnecessary mistakes
yeah but see I have to ask you I mean
after that first game last how how did
you steal this much how did this happen
yeah obviously needed some help from the
Wonder uh
I I think you know we just finished
playing in St Louis a few days ago and
we're still getting used to now playing
online again it's very different uh the
first game of adjusting my setup and all
that I was way too slow in the first
game two minutes against 11 is not
really it's never never ever going to
work against anybody but uh the second
game was obviously crucial bouncing back
I mean he was happy to draw at some
point I thought he got a better position
out of the opening but I kept playing I
kept fighting you know and he got low on
the clock started making mistakes but uh
uh it's a it's a very nice feeling you
have to win with black yeah and that
also a player like 11 he is just such
such a beast in these formats and of
course a very formidable opponent I have
to ask you Wesley you're the you're the
only player who's made it to the
semi-finals in the rapid portion who are
you hoping to face tomorrow we've got
three armageddes coming up
it's definitely been a
thing with white blue games I think also
he car losing with white and also myself
the thing with white so been a been a
crazy day
um
uh you know
I I guess to be honest prefer not to
play Hikaru again but it is what it is
uh I'll definitely be watching the
Armageddon and uh
you know and see what happened but I
think I think everybody has a chance
when it gets to Armageddon I think
maybe Philadelphia like a 45 chance and
maybe arcade me about like a 40 chance
it's going to be a big fight uh in
either way but I'm just very happy to
win today and still be in the winners
bracket yes congratulations Wesley big
Armageddon matches coming up and we wish
you all the best for tomorrow
thank you for joining us
wow there is so much action with three
big armageddons do not leave your chairs
right now we're going to go into a shot
twitch break and be right back
[Music]
tonight
foreign
[Music]
striking back in that game four to take
it to the Armageddon we are waiting for
the players and their bids let's take a
look at the format of the Armageddon now
that the players have tied the rabbit
potion there will be bids they will be
placing their bids and the player to
place the bids with the low lowest time
wins the bid and gets to choose the
color the opponent will start with 15
minutes that is the base time there's no
bonus increment and of course whoever
chooses black
has to has to draw gets the result odds
but white will start then with 15
minutes Robert what what is what are the
mind games right now yeah this sounds
confusing but it's actually quite simple
to work out you bid Whoever has the
lower bid they get to choose their color
they're going to choose the black pieces
because they want the draw odds in an
Armageddon game if you're the one
playing with the white pieces you need
to win a draw is not good enough you
lose the match so that's how it works so
you bid let's say I bid 10 minutes you
bid 12 minutes you get the full 15
minutes you get the white pieces but you
have to beat me yeah but the interesting
thing is right the player who beats the
lower time gets to decide the color do
you think they will def definitely pick
back yeah you're it's nice to give
people choice that way they feel like
they're free but in this case you're
gonna choose the black pieces because
you want those drawns I'm always taking
the black pictures every single time
there of course there's so many ways you
can go and today black won every game so
if I mean with the black pieces it's
absolutely going to be an advantage for
you and you get two options I either win
or I draw and I win in both I mean if
that's regular chess I'm taking black
all day absolutely no Armageddon I'm
gonna put my neck out and make a bold
prediction I think we're gonna see some
crazy low bids as people are desperate
to get black so far today we've had 16
games seven draws nine wins for black
zero wins for white crazy one-sided
something's in the air they want black
in the arm again but you know who might
not want black so much I'll say one
player in particular Liam lay he
struggled with the black pieces if we go
through those games we saw Fabian had
winning positions in two different games
of the white pieces so I wouldn't bid
too low if I'm lamb lay he actually was
much worse in critical moments so I
think Fabi is one player in this field
who might want the white pieces oh you
got a big reveal come coming up as we do
receive our first set of bids it is
Hikaru versus Federation and take a look
at this WOW Hikaru went really low there
to get the black pieces 9 minutes and 38
seconds while Fellowship bid for 12
minutes which means he would be quite
happy to get the white pieces uh I'm
shocked I've got to say Vladimir felices
lost experience with the white pieces
was a disaster such a bit that high
I'm almost speechless I think he should
have gone lower
knacker's gonna be happy I'm absolutely
believe in that too as well nakamura's
gonna be happy crushed with the black
people that was the the game of their
match of there was that fourth game I
mean you still have to shake that off as
far to save as you just absolutely got
destroyed in that last game there and
then now he cargo is black it could be
the same story oh wow and another one
Fabiano caruana win loses the bid with
10 minutes and 59 seconds even almost 11
minutes William wins the bid with nine
minutes so Liam will be deciding whether
to take white or black our experts feel
that the player who does win the bid
will choose the black pieces get the
result odds uh the other the other
player gets a full 15 minutes on the
clock but black just needs a draw and
we've seen the day has been favoring the
black pieces wow are you surprised with
this one this was a lot closer though I
think that this is risky bidding by Liam
lay because that is not a lot of time he
bid less time than a car Nakamura did
and Hikaru Nakamura is the bullet
Champion right so I think that Liam Lane
is taking a huge risk nine minutes and
29 seconds against Fabiano caruana with
that wealth of preparation that's scary
territory for me yeah that is scary
actually he needs to survive the opening
he's had a couple of disasters in the
opening phase and it's not going to be
easy I agree with completely Robert 100
and there's also the psychological win
right about winning the big bid and we
have our final bid here and take a look
at that Magnus Carlson absolutely
desperate for the black pieces bit down
to 7 Minutes 58 seconds is this the
lowest bit that we've seen in the
championship
I think so wow in the last tournament
two months ago the Athens Masters we saw
Magnus and Hikaru try to outbid each
other they were both over eight minutes
though if I remember correctly here I
mean that is a massive risk he could get
flagged easily at some point I'll tell
me if we'll just try to play on the
clock James is that disrespectful he is
very disrespectful but also you know
what he says I'm world champion and I
want to play Blitz and I'm about to take
it to you right now this is the time
it's Armageddon I got the black pieces
or whatever whatever he chooses I'm
gonna play Blitz and I'm about to beat
you right now that's what he's saying
wow to play us with the white pieces
will start with 15 minutes black gets
result odds which means that black just
needs to draw to win the match uh Hikaru
Magnus after they come back win in that
fourth round is the momentum with them
has that shift happen David it must be
on their side you would think but these
players are so strong that Anything Can
Happen also Armageddon the nerves are
going to be jangling there will be Mouse
lips as the players try to hustle on the
clock
um yeah my predictions of the times were
maybe okay but I'm not going to make any
predictions on the result it's uh
anything can happen and I think these
are two actually quite bad opponents for
Magnus and icaro because both these
players look them up look up big fish
1995 and sib elephant on chess.com their
bullet ratings are near the top of the
platform so you do not want to be down
five minutes on the clock against them
because they will keep the speed up wow
and we've got liftoff
if I don't see I have 14 minutes right
now Hikaru with his bid has about nine
minutes there is no increment so you've
got to get a result in this much time it
is a solid opening it is the English
opening what do we think about this
approach yeah it looks like uh Hikaru he
is choosing his most solid repertoire
I've seen him use this before uh even in
candidates matches like in back uh like
back in 2016 he used this when he was
happy with the draw and uh feather say
if he's going to be burning a lot of
time on the clock just trying to keep
those winning chances alive so uh
as long as he's quick survives
the opening you'll be confident Tony
made a great Point here actually you
gotta remember guys there's no increment
when there's no increment I mean you do
have to move almost instantly especially
when you get down you know four or five
minutes from now it will be a real Blitz
game and there's no increment here now
of course hopefully you're hoping for
with the black pieces is your opponent
actually does use a lot of his time so
you can make it more even there and
chances are are better for black there
but that time Edge is definitely huge
and I use the word disrespect but there
is no such thing of respecting when you
need to win if you are federal save or
you're uh temiev or you're Fabiano
caruana if you see that your opponent is
in a rook end game that should be a draw
but they don't have time you are going
to flag them you have no other option so
Pharaoh save he is nasty when it comes
down to Mere seconds on the clock and I
feel like for Hikaru he needs to be very
careful and play very quickly in this
early stage
yep that being said I do believe that
fedesaf he will be trying to play
quickly his opening hasn't been a
success look at what White's done so far
he's retreated his Knights Black's
pieces are Super Active this black
knight in the center is surprisingly
hard to get rid of unless you're willing
to really weaken your own King
I think nakamura's got the dream
position out of the opening and he
hasn't burnt that much time he spent
less than a minute so far Nakamura and
uh yeah he's keeping the pressure on at
the moment keeping Pace with each other
but uh I prefer uh prefer Black's
chances on the board looks perfect for
you James I love it you can't move too
fast as white here because I mean black
he's just gonna pound so you mean Carl
is going to pounce if you move too fast
without Precision here so of course
black species are very active I do like
the Knight on D4 he goes rookie one to
defend E2 he also wants to play B4 in
many cases here as well black needs to
get something going there it is D5
activating his pieces or the Pawns in
the center here making some trades here
and uh trying to open things up but I'm
okay with again the draw hey you can
trade everything off if you like big
fella we go into a draw and I would win
this anyway
really needs to keep the pressure up on
the clock that is is Big chances Big
Hope flagging is absolutely allowed and
not dirty at all when it comes to the
army guys it's recommended what do you
mean we want that but right now what
federal save wants is he wants to carve
out the light squares the one bit of bad
news forehead cars that Bishop on H5
that light score Bishop it's out of play
and look at how directly Federal save is
trying to punish him B7 the queen is
attacking that pawn up there it's also
on the diagonal hitting the pawn on D5
so this is a problem for Hikaru Nakamura
he may have to give up the bishop pair
in order to keep the material equal here
I like Federal saves position I know
David at first it was okay for Carl but
that's when you just don't have quite
enough time you need to make quick moves
and that's when mistakes happen I
completely agree I loved hikaru's
position but after one set of nitrates
suddenly things aren't so simple anymore
a double attack these two pawns hit and
you don't really want to have to
eliminate this Knight the more pieces
that come off the board you would think
you're more solid but white gets the
bishop pair and here also a nice attack
on the open file against this B Pawn
your car is playing for tricks now A4
what is that can the pawn be taken it
looks like there might be some double
attacks hitting the Rook hitting the
Knight but the Knight just slides back
and white is grabbed upon looks like a
bluff to me third yes yes well I'm
taking that I mean you had to show me
bro are you down on time Knight takes 95
yeah he says show me what you got yeah
is he a poker player wow it's as if he's
going all out for the win it's as if he
needs to win at all costs Hikaru but
he's uh yeah he's just a pawn down he
needs to create some contemplation now
going on the attack maybe throwing the
spawn forward later if possible opening
up lines he's going to try and swing his
Rook across still anything can happen
but why does it pawn up oh but this is
this has got to be a bit of a disastrous
outcome for Hikaru out of the opening
you want to keep everything solid you're
looking for that draw you don't want
chaos when you've got little time on the
clock he can't be happy at all with this
he's down a pawn and he doesn't have the
compensation so I think right now we're
looking at a Vladimir Fellowship who is
determined he played really poor Chess
By His lofty standards in that fourth
and final game of Rapid but right here
in the arm again look at the clocks he
started with a five and a half minute
lead he remains five minutes ahead in
the clock and he's up a pawn and akara's
task is not getting any easier and the
evaluation bar is going up in federal
sales favor it's easy for him to play
this I'm very worried for Nakamura right
now look at him shake his head there she
was like what is this this is this is
garbage what am I doing I'm a
right what is he doing that's what
he's saying right now of course but he
did move a little bit too fast I mean he
has to move fast in the way as he is
down time here but it made a critical
mistake he's down a pawn now there is
chances still left there he's going to
try to create some chances make things
tricky because we know he's the one of
the greatest to do that I mean just look
at that Magnus Swindle that just
happened earlier today so anything can
happen here but definitely in White's
favor yeah down upon and down five and a
half minutes
bar it's just slowly and suddenly
inching forward and forward forward
Nakamura looking more and more
frustrated with his position this is a
nightmare down upon he's trying to look
for compensation while he tries to find
it let's take a look at our other very
important very crucial Armageddon we've
got two more on this is Magnus taking on
vladislavartamia we also have Fabiano
caruana against Liam fighting it out wow
this one is a lot more stable and calm
yeah this looks like nine-year-old
Robert Hess playing I used to love the
clothes Sicilian you see not a single
piece has been traded white not looking
that ambitious at the time uh but look
at the clock right so for artemia I
don't actually think this is an unwise
strategy I like it because he's just
keeping the pieces on the board and that
makes it more difficult to play quick
moves it also means you can't just force
a draw so I think that for our temmiev
he's playing for the clock more so than
the position
yep certainly and Magnus he's gonna have
to make difficult decisions like his
last move just in no time at all and
this last move is committal yes you
might achieve a trade of Bishops you
would think that guy too closer to the
draw but there's still so much tension
White's F Pawn at some point could step
forward maybe there'll be a sudden Blitz
attack against the black king you have
to be really wary here really careful of
how the position develops and to be
honest I would choose white I'm not a
huge fan of this opening in general but
with a four or five minute clock
advantage in such a tense situation I
think it's an opening success for
Artemis and queen uh Queen jumping or
jumping in there yeah it's getting spicy
and spicy but okay maybe after he just
takes back I mean where's the spice like
Spice wear you know spice it all in this
position in fact after that and as a
Robert mention here I mean just keeping
the pieces on the board it makes you
think right so you have to think about
where I want to put my pieces what can I
do in this type of situation like I mean
everything's just all nice and Compact
and like very tight making trades look
at this he wants to trade maybe try
Bishop F6 I mean yeah you're definitely
white here f six Bishop back to E3 we
can trade Knight D5 things like that
yeah F6 isn't actually possible right
now maybe it could just be taken uh so
if black can't block this attack against
his Knight maybe we'll see a trade
Bishop for Knight and white tonight
jumping into this beautiful outpost on
D5
strategic kind of switch up there from
artemia but it makes a lot of sense
black under some pressure for sure grab
that and take the D5 Square I mean white
is having all the fun here that Bishop
on G7 although if you do take on E7 at
some point it might slide out to HS you
have to be careful about giving up new
diagonals all that being said I think
the r10 map he has the pressure his
Rooks are doubled they're staring into
the black position that D5 square is
Juicy for that Knight to hop into and
that's the nature of when two pawns are
two squares apart the square in between
is your opponents for the taking and
that Knight should hop right in yeah so
just eliminate this Knight the only
Challenger the only defender of that
Outpost and uh I think you're safe
enough to jump in right now the Black
Brook will move I'm not sure where and
uh you will get a chance at some point
evicted this Black Knight too the dream
scenario for white we should mention is
a good night versus bad Bishop here
beautiful night and really ugly Bishop
as its counterpart kind of staring at
its own Pawn so here white would be in
full control big positional Advantage
maybe strategically winning we would say
but uh Magnus needs to fight against
that this is actually the position we
have on the board right now uh we
predicted it by accident but uh yeah can
I'll tell me I've forced these Knights
off in a favorable situation you could
even make an argument for taking them
off right now I would choose white also
four minutes up on the clock on the
clock one's gotta admire our time he has
mental fortitude in this position in
this game going into the Armageddon
after what happened after almost
wrapping it up in the rapid with a
winning position and then a drawn
position against Magnus in that fourth
game but one slip and here he is
fighting it out but playing it to
Perfection so far creating keeping his
chances archievement has to win if this
ends in a draw Magnus takes the match is
Magnus taking a nap right now yeah he
sleeps yeah he fell asleep yeah it's
almost too much partying out there in
that poker you know what I mean out
there yeah he's sleeping oh he's up all
right maybe he just hates his position
I think it's life choices but uh this
one's difficult oh tell me if though is
tanking a little bit he slowed down lost
his time Advantage he started with with
what was it seven extra minutes and uh
that's dwindled down to three or so yeah
but he does play C3 black has to dodge
this trade of knights don't swap off
don't give yourself that good night
versus bad Bishop scenario and there we
go
great idea there by David because the
Knight on D5 cannot be kicked out by a
pawn and it's going to stay there you
don't want to give up a rook for a night
so this Knight at some point may have to
trade off this bishop on G7 eventually
would like to get to a better diagonal
but it doesn't look very pleasant for
black for the time being all right well
we will come back to this let's go back
to the Hikaru Pharisee of action that is
heating up let's bring the Armageddon
and here we are Hikaru Nakamura needs
just a draw to win the match but
fetusive is he completely in control
dominating the position yeah we might
get our first White win of the day not
only is fair to save a clear Pawn up
he's got a two versus one poor majority
on the queen side but you can grab
another Pawn why not just take this Pawn
that you've been offered personally in
the center but I was going to say the H
Pawn and look at those white Bishops
have you ever seen such beautiful pieces
these Bishops look very good and look at
the Knight on B5 in fact I mean that's
such a strong piece I mean he's like
yeah Trey bro I'm up you know you're not
this piece is the pieces don't look good
it it's almost like the it flipped
from the last game that they had right
with the pieces were really bad on the
back Rank and that's kind of what it
looks like now okay now he goes Bishop
B6 to hit E3 trying to get a little bit
of activity but again he is down a pawn
and a draw if he's able to swindle
something here he could and the draw
does help he will win but I mean man
look at that eval bar too yikes yeah
takes takes work C8 is there I mean you
got Rook takes Bishop takes and maybe
you have to move the Knight there
I think yikes is the right word
looking really really bad for black uh
you do have to take with the bishop you
can't allow the white Rook into your
camp now the White Knight will move but
plenty of good choices plenty of good
squares I would probably pick the D4
square if I had to uh just because it
blocks uh the black dark Square Bishop
it covers the whole board and still
looking good for white three minutes up
on the clock still as well B7 saying you
know yeah I was about to say that right
it's easy to forget that pawn is hanging
from the light score Bishop for white so
everything is just problematic for black
also down upon your pieces are less
active you got nothing going for you and
you're down nearly three minutes on the
clock yeah he's swindled worse positions
in this Hikaru but uh he really needs a
bit of luck on his side now he's going
for White's a pawn but that can simply
be defended look at the white rook and
black Rook now on a really passive
Square it must be the case that white
can improve look at that look at those
Bishops the centralization show this to
your kids this is beautiful for white
and uh the black king trying to slide
over to the center but not really
achieving too much there
looking good for feder safe definitely
good but you still can't push the pawns
on the queen side and white has to find
a way to break in what is the plan
forward with the Rook stock defending
the A3 Pawn well he's shown us he
brought his King towards the center he's
like let's help those pawns maybe that
King can go all the way over to protect
that A3 pawn it is loose but he throws
in Bishop B8 he goes back and forth but
he goes to a safer Square farther away
from Black's pieces don't be surprised
if he throws in a check here or a threat
there so I feel like for federal save
he's also leading on the clock and he is
one of the best of bullets in both
players and wait a second yeah
oh my goodness thanks for the generosity
wow that's a rep he realized immediately
Nakamura uh you spotted it too and uh
fair to say have two pawns up now
I'm up on the clock as well he's played
this really well taking advantage of all
the misses by Hikaru and not spending
too much time also these little moves
right it forces Hikaru to burn the clock
more and more and with no increment
that's further pressure it's been a
little move the night is great on D4 but
he moved it up to B5 I thought he might
even Retreat it back to F3 and into the
center but still he is just improving
his position at every turn make sure all
his pieces are defended and if he
doesn't win the game over the board he
might just try to flag Hikaru at some
point because the choices for our car
are not getting any easier as white kids
are pushing these pawns forward yeah but
you've got to be a little careful
because E4 there's this check on the d8
Square you can't really block it with
the bishop because the E4 Pawn has been
there are all these ideas that you need
to watch out which is why he keeps
things under control Hikaru trying to go
from one side to another create some
player that's what he's got to do it is
desperation for Hikaru Nakamura let's
get an update on the Magnus uh tammyev
Armageddon we've got that on David take
it away yeah we've got this one on and
look at that white knight in the center
of the board has been cemented it's like
a granite statue right now that White
Knight on D5 however black is solid
apart from that so is it enough for
white to win this game it's going to be
a good night versus bad Bishop but
Magnus is just gonna try and curl up
into a ball and defend he only needs a
draw and now the time difference is only
one minute so what do we think odds here
ah you know because the time's getting
closer I'm actually leaning on Magnus
here I do like White's position but I
mean you can't it's not like you can
really push for anything right now I
can't really make big threats right now
everything's just really solid reminds
you of the game with Liam Lee and Fabi
where the game he was down that pond but
then yeah or actually not it was the
game where it was just uh the Double
Rooks on the file kind of very similar
to this actually and I think that ended
in the draw as well but this one it draw
is not going to be good for a Timmy have
obviously so I'm going with vladislav I
think this position is closed okay Matt
doesn't have an easy way to liquidate
trade pieces and I feel like the time of
edge is still huge and artemium is that
great a bullet he's over 3 100 sheets I
mean that guy does not fool around he
knows how to work the clock he knows how
to flag his opponent and he will have no
shape
if it comes down to a blocked position
where ultimate has two minutes Magnus
says one you can play Forever Play 49
moves push your Pawn play 49 minutes and
then flag your opponent there but uh
yeah meanwhile Magnus he's gone to the
edge of the board for this Knight that's
not the Final Destination clearly he's
going to reroute his Knight back uh
probably via B8 C6 and then into the
center I do think vladislav maybe missed
a small trick there by allowing the
Black Knight to dodge the trade I think
he should have uh swatched off instantly
because Knights are so tricky in these
types of positions especially when the
clock is ticking and here we go he's
getting ready to play on that flank now
the queen side he's getting ready to
throw the white points forward look at
the reroute yeah nice sophisticated
really classy move there from Magnus I
think these players are playing like
it's a classical game these little moves
here and there are all these position
strategic ideas nice juicy squares for
the pieces I love it while you've got
one more Armageddon on let's get an
update on that one Fabiano caruana takes
on Liam there have been a lot of moves
and while blacking Under Fire wow and
maybe you can go for checkmate
immediately look at this Fabiano's
switched Focus now look the White Queen
the white Rook lined up behind each
other and how do you defend the black A6
Pawn oh you don't if you don't yeah
James has it right now normally a Pawn's
best friend's another Pawn you push it
forward but the pawn in front of the
king is pinned which means that White
Queen is supposed to grab it all James
this is your kind of game oh absolutely
this is game over of course you take on
A6 right now to King moo Queen B7
tactics I smell something well no Queen
trade exactly right now Queens are queen
A4 of course and look at the time edge
of course City he has I mean Liam has
been very very bad with his black games
today I mean maybe he should take white
taken white maybe try his chances there
this one's just clean Advantage for
white I mean we can even try to switch
sides Queen B4 and try to go to the
others the other way before it hits the
Rook you can go check on f8 and there it
is come on Fabi I know yeah probably if
you you know get some money you can send
that this way absolutely he's coming in
he's invading and not just that but but
also less than two minutes on the clock
for Leanne there's no way you survive
this attack in general but with two
minutes it's uh even more hopeless and
oh my goodness here we go full invasion
that is a meeting one question it is a
big threat he defends it with Rook D6
queen of seven hits the king hits that
one oh okay stay on the board you called
it David this would be resigns and we
see Fabiano he picks up his water bottle
and we know what that means he's gonna
pick up the Rook yeah he is and now it's
an extra work you know them like he
doesn't want to play on but he loses the
match if he resigns he loses the match
if he gets Checkmate so he's just gonna
play a few more moves but this one is
over yeah full Rook down now and getting
attacked yeah this one his husband
decided Fabi nice breakthrough and it
was just a comparison of the Kings the
whole time the white king safely tucked
away in bed nice and safe and the black
king has been chased to its death and
continues to be chased into that corner
Checkmate is coming yeah and just
leaning into the screen trying to finish
it off in style yeah made another run of
King runs the G7 why does Upper Rock
is this one Fabiano caruana will be the
second semi-finalist queen of Fate will
be unstoppable uh expecting Liam to
resign very hard to defend this no
checks on the board and that is it
Fabiano caruana is true to the
semi-finals we've got action on on the
other Armageddon and Hikaru against
fedorship Felicia have completely
winning he's got two he's got two extra
pawns two passers on the board yeah
normally opposite color Bishops do Grant
some drawing chances even if you're two
pawns down but here it looks like you
can't stop the white B Pawn from
reaching the seventh rank one square
away from promotion that will paralyze
at least one of Black's two pieces the
black bishop or King and uh the other
Pawn will do the work here yeah it does
look like it's too many points
unfortunately as he calls it himself on
the stream the wide peoples here is uh
which is the Pawns in fact the b-pawn
and the e-pawn being wide peoples are a
very very a big problem here and we are
and we can actually grab the G Pawn too
as well so white has just so much play
and we're up on the clock yeah to me it
looks like bowling when you got that
split you can't get them all and of
course for black you can't control them
all these pawns are uncontainable
they're going to the other side and it's
very important actually that there's two
of them on the B file because sometimes
King takes one your Bishop takes the
other but there's still one more Pawn
that will be remaining and that's going
to be a win for federal save and I mean
he looked out of it in the fourth game
of the match but somehow he was able to
get his composure back yeah also still
up on the clock he's maintained that
time advantage since moved uh since move
one and the only job to do here is make
sure your e-pawn your Central Point does
not get blockaded whoa that one's a bit
risky
I knew I knew that would happen
that's a cheap one it's not stalemate
just yet you can't give up your piece
not yet but the evaluation
look at him oh my goodness and the
reason why is because when you keep
pushing your Pawn the bishop will
sacrifice and the white king is too far
away to defend those Queen side pawns
that is unbelievable I think he had to
move he had to he had to keep that in
reserve he had to King up around he
rushed it yeah he rushed it absolutely
and this could be over it's totally
impractical he could have played this
any move over the next 50 turns he
rushed it and suddenly it's the worst
possible moment and he's realizing and
if this ends in a draw it means that
Carl wins the match and Robert there is
no way to get away from what you're
saying black gives up the bishop for the
pawn just advances the Jeep on down the
board gives that up and it is a
stalemate there is no running away from
it
I am I'm in shock right now this is just
heartbreaking for Fellowship you gotta
try to flag him I'm serious like they're
I know
put your Bishop back you push upon make
like 50 moves then you finally like
bring your king back and sacrifice one
of your Pawn you just have to do
something crazy and try to flag the guy
I'm serious keep one point on the board
and that's it but his time Advantage is
gone so even that option is out the
window oh there's nothing yeah
absolutely nothing and just G4 now yeah
that's it and uh yeah if the white
pointer pushed forward Bishop to A3
would have been a check and actually we
see that now the white king moves and
Black's Bishop is ready anytime that
white Pawn steps forward to sacrifice
itself stalemate is inevitable but do
you have a number of 15 move rules that
you're disposal that's important rule in
chess if 50 moves are played Without a
pawn push or a capture the game is a
draw so what federal save wants to do is
we have to give up a pawn and that way
the 50 move counts starts counting again
and you look at his car's clock he's
down 30 seconds Federal Sav is a beast
at bullet and now what he's gonna do is
play right now 49 quick moves you need
to keep an eye on the Move counter and
then he'll push his Pawn give it away
then you know moves Bishop at some point
he's got to do things like that and uh
he covered just in case
this is just a flagging battle that is
the only hope Robert that's a great call
on the strategy of what photos you have
is trying to do right now excellent call
problem is yes you up the white epon but
as soon as that pawn is given up black
will never need to capture anything else
and it won't be any 50 move anymore
there won't be any more 50 moves so you
can go 49 moves give up a pawn then the
counter resets another 50 moves and then
that's it so Hikaru needs to make a
maximum of 99 moves from a few moves ago
you can do it 71 seconds plenty of time
99 moves Chad do you hear that that's
amazing can you make 99 moves in 70
seconds easy easy
all right because this is going to go on
let's take a look at the Magnus
Armageddon there is just too much drama
in the chasseable Masters and look at
this that is just dominating this
position drug cheesecake
just blunder
of smoke oh my goodness he says drop off
Knight to D3 Rook G6 came over yep
tactical wizard exact calculation over
everything for everything speak get him
off the board that one hurts
he's got a flag him yeah
I think he's having a psychological
battle whether he should go for the
flagging or not in a dead lost
possession he should no he absolutely
should I mean he's still a chance yeah
but you always think about it you don't
be respectful here the reason why he was
in trouble over the boards he's enough
time to calculate so if your opponent
doesn't have time flag them no thinking
how do you win this in 20 seconds uh you
might not but he's doing a pretty decent
job push the pawn
Queen for Rook Advantage but there are
some checks against the white king as
well okay 20 seconds is it enough he
gives a check okay seven no no watch out
for a minute watch out for the king but
th3 I smell this and Rook takes F3 is
always available
but 10 seconds
he's not pre-moving he spent so much
time there's no increment oh wow there
could be some Checkmate threats around
here oh the Pawn's gone oh my gosh she's
not gonna win
he's not going to he's not got any any
time just oh now there's gonna be
checkmates again
oh my God
wow
the queen D5 is meat oh he doesn't
matter
normally bees sting once and they die
but vladison Montana will not die he
takes down the world champion wow that
was sick that was sick absolutely great
I mean he stung him there and the world
champion is going down and he's going to
be in the losers bracket unbelievable
wow especially I mean I guess I guess
you know he what happened was that
Swindle that Magnus got and then it just
kind of came back on him in this game
wow but that's insane that our Timmy F
was able to take this
we didn't get to see the end of that
game oh okay cool yeah they probably
almost 78 right now
finally oh my God 127. yeah you can't
flag Hikaru can you no I don't want to
look at me I can't that's for sure I
thought I thought Federal Sav could
though he's really good
unbelievable Hikaru Nakamura does manage
to survive finishing that game in a
stalemate that was that lost he survives
he draws the game which means that he
wins the match and it is our time you
have who beat Magnus Carlson taking it
to the same final we've got Magnus
Carlson joining us
Magnus what a match this was taking it
to the Armageddon sum it up for us
I mean it was a pretty
pretty uh bad
um
uh you generally you know uh played me
in the the third game
um first was yeah just
barrage of blunders really but I mean
the last game was was terrible I played
um one very poor idea and I was much
worse but I mean I
I had this strike with F4 after which I
should never lose I mean I was even up
on time but
so uh he managed to find resources I
thought Knight H4 and wrote G4 was
really strong and then yeah I just
hung the queen
um and then
uh after that I still had some minor
hope when it
uh when it came to the time situation
but obviously it was it was tough and
Magnus you bid 7 minutes 59 seconds for
the Armageddon
what was the what was the mindset on
that it felt that it was too low in the
studio we were discussing but you really
wanted the black pieces
well I mean
thoughts
uh I I'd be fine with the black pieces I
didn't I wasn't particularly worried
that he would outplay me so I thought
let's just ensure that I'm black uh but
I right after I had bids
um I I thought about it and I thought
um he's not the kind of guy who did very
lowest black so I should have tried to
optimize some bit a little bit more so
um
but I mean too low I mean what is what
is too too low I mean the game's a bit
one with uh with the those you know uh
times in in other tournaments so that's
um that's fun and as you saw the time
was in the um the issue yeah and Magnus
for tomorrow how do you now reset and
prepare for the match tomorrow
I don't know
um this was a really really awful day of
uh chess
um like I did everything to lose and
then some uh obviously you know it takes
a strong opponent to to exploit that but
that was really pretty poor so we'll see
I'll um
um to do my best tomorrow but this yeah
this is unacceptable
Magnus we really appreciate you joining
us thank you and all the best for
tomorrow
thank you
wow Magnus Carlsen will be in
elimination bracket he's used one of his
lives our tamiyev with a big win over
the world champion let's take a look at
the results of the day and we saw Magnus
surviving the rapid potion taking it to
the Armageddon our time we are striking
in that and he wins his match Fabiano
caruana with a fabulous game in the
Armageddon beats Liam Hikaru Nakamura
Fantasia what a match that was going
into the Armageddon and then Hikaru dead
lost
it's just I don't know how he does it
Robert Fellowship did slip that and with
that he combination where I managed to
find the still managed to not get
flagged and takes that match Wesley so
against Lavon aronian ended in the rapid
potion with Wesley qualifying to the
samis wow what a day guys Robert your
thoughts it's been an incredible day I
mean ups and downs for all the players
so many wins with the black pieces but I
think what I the highlights artemiov
takes down Magnus Carlson we said it you
might have believed it but it did happen
artemium is that strong Federal Sev
almost did the same but I feel like he
just let it slip out of his graph he was
winning in the Armageddon he was up two
to one in you know the regulation the
rapid and he just gave hikara a golden
chance and you can't do that not once
let alone twice against Nakamura yeah
one of the day if she asked me that and
we we've got joining us our other
semi-finalist Fabiano Carana from St
Louis Fabi hi congratulations
hi Tanya thanks
Fabi it went into the Armageddon but
even the rapid portion of the match
against Liam it looked like you were the
one pushing tell us how was this day and
uh how did you take this away
yeah I I had a few disappointing games
I felt like in the uh in the first four
games I was like very clearly ahead in
most of the games I don't think I was
ever seriously worse and I had two
completely winning positions uh just
like mathematically winning uh in a
night end game
and then I was of a queen and even that
wasn't enough to win
so that was quite disappointing but I I
was happy with the openings that's why I
was quite optimistic about Armageddon
because I thought with white I'm getting
a fight and if I have to play with black
then I'm not really suffering yet
of course you never know an Armageddon
it's always
going to come down to random time
scramble very often or um
you know you can lose very quickly with
the black pieces uh I've also seen
people lose very quickly with the white
pieces like against Levon recently I've
played an Armageddon game I lost um
like I made it so that wasn't too great
so um but anyway I was rather optimistic
Fabiano were you at all surprised by
Liam's bid because in the studio we
thought it was quite low especially
considering how good the positions you
got with the white pieces were in the
rapid
yeah you know I thought 1059 was my bid
and I thought it's going our bids will
be rather close I had a feeling and then
he surprised me by 9 29 and then
suddenly I saw that Magnus bid 7 29 or
what was it something like that and I
was like what's going on I mean
like magnus's bit I thought was really
really surprising because you're you're
taking half the time of your opponent
um yeah I was very surprised but I guess
he was rather confident about his
chances with black I was happy to get to
get the white pieces even though we had
drawn all the games I still thought I
would get chances
Fabiano great chess today man yeah of
course it was some ups and downs but you
made it through right so of course we
saw it on your Instagram that you you've
been lifting weights you've been
squatting getting real low in the
trenches there so of course how much
does that contribute to your chest
well I don't know if I do it for chess
so much but uh it's something that I do
for enjoyment and I like to you know I'm
very competitive I like even if I'm not
competing with someone else I'd like to
compete with myself and uh with lifting
even though I'm of course a complete
beginner still it's nice to see progress
and uh to get some new new records new
personal records it always feels good
uh so so this is something I've been
doing relatively recently
um but it can't hurt to to be in good
shape as well
and uh congrats of course Fabi a couple
of months ago you won the air things
Masters division two to qualify for
division one this time you played in the
American Cup you're back here again is
this a format you love now is it
something you're getting used to the
double the limb
yeah well it's very stressful so
um I guess it's fun for the people
watching but I have to say for the
players it can be it can be rather
rather tiring like especially the um the
American couple okay I got knocked out
but at the end of it when Wesley and
Hikaru were playing the final I can't
imagine how tired they were playing like
multiple matches of you know where one
mistake cost you the match so uh I mean
we'll see it's still the first only the
first match here it could be could be a
short Journey or it could be a long one
uh as as is usually the case it's always
rather unpredictable
but but the the fun thing is that
um you always have something on the line
like in in a classical tournament let's
say a round robin system you know very
often some players who are making a lot
of draws or who weren't having the best
tournament they lose motivation at the
end but in in match play format or in
the elimination format then you always
have uh something on the line everyone's
always super motivated so I think that's
that's one really really good things
about this format yeah and Fabio had
such a fantastic day of Chess going into
three army guns what are your thoughts
on this field it just feels like
such a dangerous mix of players
yeah and I think it's a great field and
we saw today that anyone can get
eliminated Magnus lost to vladislav
um which I I thought that it would be a
tough match I of course Magnus is a
favorite but uh I wasn't surprised to
see that he was struggling because a lot
of stuff is also so well so so strong
and was playing quite well and also
Hikaru against ferrose normally Hikaru
would be quite a big favorite but he was
struggling quite a lot and to be honest
it was a miracle that he I mean when I
saw this final position B6 Visa B7 and
the e-plun it's like so unfair that
white doesn't win this why does three
pawns up and if you take away the B6
Pawn white wins but somehow this extra
B6 Pawn costs cost to win it's it's
amazing
um
an amazing formation actually uh shows
how how resourceful Hikaru is to spot
this that this is um a chance to save
the game especially when you're playing
Armageddon you know that you could get
flagged and very often the impulses to
rush and
um well Hikaru is always keeping us cool
especially in bad positions so but
anyway we saw that anyone can win anyone
can lose these matches uh whether you're
you know the highest rated player or uh
or not you know everyone is very strong
play that thank you so much Bobby and
congratulations on making it to the
semis we will see you tomorrow
thank you
and now we've got joining us the big
winner
vladislavartamya who took down world
champion Magnus Carlton Ian and Hill
biting Armageddon our time you have
congratulations
thank you very much
all right Damian what a match this was
but before we got to the Armageddon I
have to ask you it must have been maybe
a little disappointing that it even got
that far because you played so well in
the rapid
uh I think that at least it was a very
good match because as usual Magnus very
interesting and strong component and you
have big challenge
every time uh about much I think that I
played good but sometimes I have uh
troubles this time on the clock
so it was my problem maybe but it's not
easy to have many time against Magnus
uh I think that uh two games when I have
black was very comfortable for me and I
won all games
uh but with white was problem uh for
Magnuson for me
and of course I was very disappointed
when I lost lost Rhodesian game
uh
because I think that I have great chat
chances on the Drone objectively it's
just draw but I lost finally and of
course after this is
I have situation
um when I I know
uh nothing about
Armageddon because it's my first time
and I I told arbutarism that I want to
have black and 11 minutes
and waiting
well vladislav congratulations that's
such a big achievement by you but the
question I have is not about Chess I'm
wondering what are those pictures behind
you on the wall over there
ah it's an interesting question but it's
a good uh from TV because I have a
little child and my daughter laughs with
his uh
cat
um so if you go to shop and uh
take it yeah
very cool that Islam congratulations I
have a question here my question is how
do you stay so calm when you like we see
emotion from you now you're smiling but
I this is like the first time I've ever
seen you smile in fact actually when
you're playing you look like a
cold-blooded killer calm playing anybody
doesn't matter who you play how do you
stay so calm
um but it's very easy I I just love
chess and
every time when I playing against strong
and famous opponent it's a good day and
uh I'm really waiting this
about smile I think that it's very
individual but uh
I think that I'm positive usually so
it's my way and I like this
and vladislav beating Magnus is of
course fantastic but what are your goals
for the rest of this event
uh
to the next stage after a series
tournament
here I wanted
one match at least but now I will just
continue playing chess and we'll see I
think that next opponent will be Fabiana
probably
and it will be another good match and we
will prepare and have a good sleep I
hope
wow I'm still thinking about this match
and it was just such fantastic play by
you I have one more question about the
Armageddon uh when you got that winning
position when you won magnus's Queen
were you at any point a little scared
that you might get flagged there
uh in this moment I was uh fully
understanding that I have a very bad
position and
it's just like uh collapse and my mind
was that a few moves and I will
recession but uh
I have last counter play with the Knight
on H4 or Country 2 and Magnus
make a
very big mistakes Nike dream and in this
moment I understood that I must have
been but I must play quickly because
your usual problem this time yeah
and you did just that and managed to
Checkmate the world champion
congratulations our time you have and we
wish you all the best for tomorrow's
semi-final
super performance today thanks a lot
see you next time
thank you wow that is doing what if you
can do he defeated Magnus Carlton in a
mini match taking it to the Armageddon
he was dominating the rapid as well what
a performance what a day of Chess let's
take a look at our bracket of day one
and here we have it Robert your thoughts
well I think it looks a bit familiar if
you look at the winner semi-final Hikaru
Wesley they got here through unfamiliar
means hickar barely escaped but the top
looks very different we have vladisoft
artemia taking on Fabiano caruana you'd
love to see two new entrants making
their Mark in the event already our 10
minutes said I'm here just to play chess
I just want to win one match he beat the
world champion who's now down in the
losers bracket yeah you haven't seen
that happen before James that's crazy I
mean that's my biggest takeaway today is
our Timmy that was just a tense matchup
of course the car will match with uh two
it was very crazy but biggest takeaway
here is our Tunes just taking down
Magnus that's insane taking down the
world champion with confidence with the
face that he had being calm and stolic
like that that's is that's just Next
Level I can't wait to see what he does
in the rest of this uh tour
sure yeah and all I can say is that the
level's been so high just expect the
unexpected because everyone could be
everyone there were three armageddons
today the margins were so small a few
seconds here or there one move here or
there we could see nakalusa as much as
well but uh yeah tomorrow it does get
spicy Magnus in the elimination bracket
it's only two games imagine if he gets
eliminated more shocks ahead
what an action-pack division one this
was but also there was a lot of action
in division two take a look at the big
match results we had we're not a back up
to satro destroy the niche Curry two and
a half to half yeah the kids are all
right you see abusatarov he takes down
Geary in just three games our generic
beat his fellow teenage compatriot
rhinoxidwani but Dennis lesvik that has
to be the biggest UPS of the day for
those who don't know but for us in the
know Dennis lazwick is a monster back in
the chess.com Global championship in the
very first round he actually almost beat
Wesley so Wesley won the whole thing but
he almost lost in the initial round so
lazovic is super strong and of course
down the bottom Vladimir kromek the
former world champion yeah the 14th
World Champion and he's been so close to
make it to division one there's so much
at stake in division two ten thousand
dollars for the first prize tour points
also the golden ticket to the next
Champions chest story event it would be
amazing to see Vlad fight it out in
division one I think we'd all be happy
but hey you still got it
absolutely and there's also division
three that's been super exciting today
David yep super exciting is the right
word that Tanya so many big names more
really Top Class Grandmasters I want to
shout out for chakra mamajarov winning
his match and that legend himself
gattacamski all of these really
experienced players showing their class
also Alexei Serrano division one last
time but starts with a win this time in
division three
this was just just insane chat I mean
what we witnessed today the drama the
Armageddon the brilliances we call it
brilliances blunders time scrambles at
the start of the show and we had it all
right James this was your first show in
Oslo oh my God and what a way to start
that's amazing I'm here with the team
the team here I see you Chad it's lovely
it's amazing I'm just glad to be here of
course and see the chess and you always
get a lesson when you're watching these
guys right I love commentary because
just like free lessons really you're
watching these guys you get to check
things right you get to see the blunders
you get to say I play that opening oh
I'm never gonna do that and like in all
kinds of things like that so it's
amazing I'm glad to be yours wow
loved every moment of the day every
single moment every single game what an
amazing day of Chess this was chat thank
you so much for watching all the action
with us we will be back tomorrow Magnus
Carlsen the world champion is in the
elimination bracket he has only only one
life left the drama continues we will
see you tomorrow same time same place
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
pops
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]